de voir la salle comble ce soir désolé
pour ceux qui nous regardent en direct
parce qu'on diffuse aussi ce soir en
direct pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu venir
en physique mais là c'est très agréable
voire une salle pleine ce soir alors
juste avant de commencer à me rappeler
2,3 petit réglage va demander à tout le
monde de portée je me permets le temps
de l'introduire je le remettrais après
de couper au téléphone portable pour
essayer de ne pas déranger pas mal
pendant l'intervention
quand tout ça sera fait on pourra
démarrer sereinement pour démarrer je
vais quand même me présentait donc
romain déléris président des ja de
l'aveyron ravi ce soir d'accueillir
monsieur jancovici un dur c'est comme ça
qu'on colon qu'on l'a présentée entre
nous en préparant cette cette conférence
sur le sujet qui qui est totalement
d'actualité la compétition juste de de
se clôturer donc je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion de revenir sur ces sur ces
sujets là en introduction je pense qu'il
ya plusieurs personnes à remercier je
vais remercier le couple de camboulazet
son président bernard cazals ici
présents le conseil départemental qui
nous accueille dans ses dans ses locaux
c'est toujours un soutien important
remercié pauline qui a organisé de
manière logistique ces échanges et puis
remercié aurélien qui va animer ce ce
soir et
qui ce même si peu engagés et on va les
excuser si si ça si ça ça va ça va bien
se passer on va là on va parler m on va
on va pas lui mettre la pression on voit
la bonne soirée à tous
soyons attentifs
soyons attentifs et et puis gardons nos
questions et et pozo lieu parce que je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
intéressantes à apprendre de la de la
série bones conférence à tout le monde a
hâte au régime
bonsoir bonsoir à tous donc merci à tous
d'être présent on accueille aujourd'hui
à rodez monsieur jancovici donc je vais
le présenter très rapidement c'est un
des experts français de la transition
écoénergétiques fondateur de notamment
de carbone 4 on entend beaucoup parler
de démarches de bilan carbone voilà ça
c'est en fait partie il est aussi
fondateur et président de the chief
projet que c'est avec pour objectif de
réduire la dépendance de notre économie
aux énergies fossiles
vous avez pu voir le titre on a baptisé
cette conférence +2° les vaches sous les
cocotiers pour le titre il est il est un
petit peu provoc comme on a l'habitude
de le faire l'idée c'est que aux jeunes
agriculteurs
on n'a pas peur des débats on aime bien
bousculer les idées reçues on entend
beaucoup parler de l'agriculture du
réchauffement climatique de la
transition énergétique
on a notamment le chiffre comme quoi
l'agriculture serait à l'origine de
caisse pour 15 % des gaz à effet de
serre bon très bien mais à partir de ce
constat là est ce qu'on va plus loin est
ce qu'on est ce qu'on ne peut pas se
demander si l'agriculture aujourd'hui
notamment notre agriculture aveyronnaise
notre agriculture d'élevage notre
culture de montagne est ce qu'elle peut
pas être aussi une opportunité de même
dans la transition écologique et
énergétique et lutter aussi contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est un peu le
déroulé de cette conférence je les
semaines dans la parole à monsieur jean
cau ici
[Applaudissements]
je suis absolument désolé moi je vais
pas avoir un accent aussi chantant que
celui des deux personnes qui m'ont
précédé vous allez devoir supporter
monde henry blacksell maxent parisien
j'espère que vous vous ennuierez pas
avant la fin à cause de ça
alors je vous ai pris au pied de la
lettre
donc la question c'est est-ce que
l'avenir va ressembler à ça voilà alors
je vous ai pas pris au pied de la lettre
mais quand même un jeu un peu vous
réveiller il faudrait quand même pas
trop qui ressemble à ça
et je pense que les éleveurs n'est pas
d'emploi n'ont plus envie qui ressemble
qu'à ça
[Rires]
mais c'est aussi un sujet dont on va
discuter ce soir nécessairement on en
parlera à la fin le sujet dont je vais
que je vais évoquer devant vous il est
il a trois déterminants on va dire un
déterminant changement climatique un
déterminant en énergie un déterminant
agriculture peut prendre un triangle par
un peu n'importe lequel de ces trois
côtés au début on va commencer par
parler de climat
le climat est enfin exactement le fait
que les hommes et les femmes ne les
oublions pas puisse perturber qui l'a
même dans ce domaine là la parité bien
respecté
c'est quelque chose qui en fait est
connu depuis assez longtemps dans deux
dans deux ans on va célébrer le
bicentenaire de la découverte de l'effet
de serre par joseph fourier
physicien que certains d'entre vous
l'ont entendu ton qui avait écrit en
1824 un papier scientifique dans lequel
il expliquait qu'il avait un effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère et que cela
conduise l atmosphère enfin le la
planète à être un peu plus chaude que si
cet effet n'existait pas et alors là je
vous montre un journal que oui paru en
1912 un journal néo-zélandais une petite
brève scientifique là dans un coin dans
lequel il est expliqué que avec tout le
charbon qu'on brûle eh bien on met
beaucoup beaucoup de co2 dans
l'atmosphère et que ça va conduire le
climat à se modifier 1912 donc l'effet
de serre
la caractéristique des gaz à effet de
serre que je vais vous expliquer dans
trente secondes à réchauffer le climat
c'est de la très vieille science ce qui
est plus moderne c'est d'avoir con ries
les implications sociétales que cela
veut dire et les conséquences que cela
pourrait avoir pendant longtemps on
s'est dit que ce n'était pas vraiment un
sujet
on va essayer de faire un tout petit peu
de physique amusante je suis désolé pour
ce corps qui le mot physique évoque des
souvenirs vraiment très très désagréable
des bancs d'école alors ici vous avez
une vue d'artiste pas de moi du reste
parce que je dessine comme un cochon
dans lequel on vous représente vous
l'aurez reconnu la surface de la terre
avec la terre ferme à droite et l'océan
à gauche et au dessus l'atmosphère avec
des nuages est encore au dessus le vide
avec très loin notre soleil
alors en fait c'est une représentation
schématique du système climatique qui se
passe dans l'atmosphère dans l'océan
ce système climatique c'est une machine
en fait en machine climatique une
machine elle a besoin d'énergie pour
fonctionner et l'énergie qui permet au
système climatique de fonctionner c'est
l'énergie soleil le soleil c'est une
très très grosse bombe thermonucléaire
permanente donc heureusement que
l'énergie nucléaire ça existe sinon on
serait tous morts dans cette salle celle
là elle se produit loin donc on n'a pas
beaucoup à la redouter et ça nous envoie
donc de l'énergie en permanence sous
forme de rayonnement qui s'appelle de la
lumière alors cette lumière elle passe
très facilement à travers l'atmosphère
sauf pour la partie qui réfléchit par
les nuages ou par les surfaces très
réfléchissants de l'atmosphère les
glaces les déserts et c est à peu près
les deux tiers sont absorbés par le sol
alors le sol quand il va absorber cette
énergie solaire il va avoir tendance à
chauffer et il va se débarrasser de
l'énergie qu'il a récupéré de plusieurs
manières la première manière qu'il a de
se débarrasser de son énergie ses de
chauffer l'air qui est juste au dessus
c'est un des déterminants de la
convection savez le fait que l'air
chauffé puis ensuite il monte il rappelé
c'est cette conviction qui crée en
étaient les cumulonimbus que vous aimez
tant et voilà donc ça c'est une des
premières manières que le sol à de se
débarrasser de son énergie une deuxième
manière que le sol à de se débarrasser
de son énergie ses d'évaporer de l'eau
exactement comme votre post refroidi
avec la sueur qui s'évapore donc on est
l'apport de l'eau et la terre est une
grosse machine à évaporer puisqu'elle
est couverte aux deux tiers d'océan et
une fois que l'eau se retrouvent dans
l'atmosphère et condense sa restitue
l'énergie qui a été utilisée pour
évaporer l'eau et ça c'est un flux de
restitution sol à l'atmosphère qui est
trois fois plus important que
l'évacuation de la chaleur par le
contact et puis le sol à une troisième
manière de se débarrasser de son énergie
qui est de rayonner de l'infrarouge vous
savez l'infrarouge c'est un rayonnement
de même nature que la lumière mais avec
des longueurs d'onde plus grande est
typiquement votre corps en est mais
c'est grâce à ça qu'on peut vous voir la
nuit avec une caméra infrarouge dans un
endroit où il y aurait absolument pas de
lumière et bien le sol c'est pareil le
sol il aimait de l'infrarouge et des
températures qui est pas très éloignée
de celle de notre corps et ce
rayonnement infrarouge
il va lui arriver un destin totalement
différent dans l'atmosphère de ce qui
est arrivé à la lumière visible il passe
pas ils passent pas parce que dans
l'atmosphère il ya des gaz qu'on appelle
des gaz à effet de serre qui sont en
fait des gaz opaque aux infrarouges émis
par la surface c'est ça la définition de
gaz à effet serre c'est très simple à
cette définition en physique c'est un
gaz qui est opaque au rayonnement qui
est émis par la terre donc transparent
la lumière en pack orient awake dans
cette affaire l'atmosphère elle récupère
par trois fois de l'énergie par le bas l
on récupère une première fois avec le
contact une deuxième fois avec
l'évaporation je pense qu'à récupérer ma
souris voilà et une troisième fois par
des infrarouges qui sont interceptés
donc l'atmosphère va récupérer elle
aussi de l'énergie et comme le sol elle
va chercher à se débarrasser de cette
énergie parce que les systèmes physiques
aime bien être à l'équilibré se
débarrasser de l'énergie qui reçoivent
alors l'atmosphère n'a qu'une seule
manière de se débarrasser de son énergie
s'est elle aussi de rayonner de
l'infrarouge elle va en rayonner dans
tous les sens et notamment il y en a une
partie qui retourne au sol et donc le
sol à cause de l'effet de serre est
chauffée une deuxième fois par rapport à
une situation où il y aurait pas de gaz
à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
si l'atmosphère terrestre d'été
totalement transparente aux infrarouges
émis par la terre la température moyenne
sur terre seraient environ 30 degrés
inférieures à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
donc il y aurait probablement pas d'eau
liquide sur terre ou très très peu et
donc vous ne seriez pas dans cette salle
et moi non plus parce que la vie telle
que nous la connaissons n'existerait pas
sans eau liquide il n'y a pas de vie
donc l'effet de serre naturel est
parfaitement bénéfique à la planète et
ce qui est en cause en ce moment c'est
son augmentation rapide c'est la
modification qui va poser problème
alors cette modification d'où elle vient
à part quand quand on touche pas au
système et bien il se met à l équilibre
c'est à dire que vu de l'espace il ya
autant qu'ils rentrent que de d'énergie
qui rendent que d'énergie qui sort la
modification qu'on va faire c'est de
mettre dans l'atmosphère des gaz à effet
de serre avec toutes nos activités
modernes donc un peu plus ça en détail
et du coup on rend l'atmosphère encore
plus opaque aux infrarouges qu'avant
donc le rayonnement à encore plus de mal
à quitter l'atmosphère pour aller vers
l'espace et il y en a une encore plus
grande partie qui est intercepté par
l'atmosphère du coup ça réchauffe encore
plus le sol et le sol il va se
réchauffer jusqu'à temps que pendant
quand le sol se réchauffe du coup le
rayonnement qu'il aimait va augmenter et
le sol va se réchauffer jusqu'à temps
que le surplus de rayonnement qu'il
aimait équilibre à nouveau ce qu'il a
perdu à cause de l'augmentation de
l'opacité de l'atmosphère donc en gros
vous baisser un petit peu vous vous
diminuer un peu la taille de la bombe
d'une baignoire faut augmenter la
pression pour qu'ils sortent toujours la
même chose et là c'est à peu près ce qui
se passe vous augmentez l'opacité aux
infrarouges terrestre il faut qu'ils
sont crash un peu plus en bas pour
qu'ils passent toujours la même chose à
travers quelque part mais ça ça veut
dire que la température déquilibre
augmente et avec ça tout un tas d'effets
qu'on verra tout à l'heure
alors les gaz qui viennent perturber les
équilibres dans l'atmosphère les voix si
vous avez du co2 dioxyde de carbone vous
avez du méthane voir d'où ça sort et
après vous avez d'autres gaz notamment
un gaz qui joue aussi un rôle enfin
exactement qui est liée aux activités
agricoles qui s'appelle le protoxyde
d'azoté
je vous en parlerai un peu plus tard
alors ces gaz à effet de serre doit ce
qu'ils sortent en partie du co2 via
l'exploitation du charbon une partie du
co2 vient d'exploitation du pétrole le
fait de brûler du pétrole crée du co2
une partie vient de l'utilisation du gaz
le gaz est naturellement fait le pétrole
est naturel aussi le charbon est naturel
aussi tout ça c'est naturel donc le gaz
c'est une énergie fossile et ça fait du
co2 quand on s'en sert vous avez la
déforestation alors la déforestation
c'est un processus amont de l'activité
agricole et c'est essentiellement du
défrichement de surfaces qui sont
couvertes de forêts pour en faire des
surfaces cultivées donc en fait on vient
dans des endroits où il ya des forêts en
coupe les arbres on les brûle
l'essentiel du temps et à la place on
installe des cultures ou des pâturages
ensuite vous avez le méthane qui a
plusieurs origines dont des origines
agricoles j'en reparlerai tout à l'heure
et enfin vous avez le reste lorsque vous
remarqué sur cette courbe c'est que ça
fait un siècle et demi que les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre augmentent et
que pour le moment absolument rien à
entraver leur progression
alors on reviendra dans pas longtemps
sur les fameuses coop mais pour le
moment je vous propose autre chose qui
n'a pas entravé la progression des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler le progrès
technique bon alors je vous ai vu un
exemple par exemple le début de
l'électricité et on entend souvent dire
quand on électrifie les choses et du
coup ça permet d'être un peu plus propre
vous voyez le début de l'électricité
s'il ya plus d'un siècle on a consommé
de plus en plus d'électricité depuis un
siècle et ça n'a pas empêché les
émissions de continuer à augmenter
on a mis les gens dans les villes il
paraît que quand on est dans les villes
on est plus on consomme moins d'énergie
pour ses déplacements peut-être mais on
a mis de plus en plus des gens dans les
villes et ça empêche pas les émissions
continuent à augmenter on a mis les gens
dans les trains s'empêche pas les
émissions de continuer à augmenter on a
créé internet
voilà et on a fait des trucs et des
machins donc d'une manière générale ce
qu'on a coutume d'appeler le progrès
technique pour le moment quand vous
regardez l'évolution des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre à aucun moment vous
pouvez vous dire ah ben tiens grâce aux
progrès techniques ça s'est arrêté
d'augmenter
jamais
le drame dans notre affaire c'est que
ces gaz à effet de serre et en
particulier le co2 une fois qu'on les a
mis dans l'atmosphère ils n'ont
strictement aucune envie de s'en aller
et c'est particulièrement vrai pour le
co2 dioxyde de carbone qui comme tous
les oxydes est une molécule extrêmement
stable il ya un oxyde que vous
connaissez très bien voulu utiliser tous
les jours parce que sinon vous sentez
mauvais sous les bras qui s'appelle l'
oxyde de dihydrogène et dans un nom plus
courants l'eau eau h2o complet dont
klaus est un dock side c'est de l'oxi
d'hydrogène eh bien ça fait des
milliards d'années que l'eau et sous
forme d'eau sur terre donc les oxydes
très très stable et une fois que le co2
et dans l'atmosphère il n'a aucun
processus spontanée d'épuration donc
tant qu'il reste au milieu de
l'atmosphère il est éternel il s'en va
pas pour que le co2 accepte de s'en
aller de l'atmosphère il faut qu'ils
reviennent au contact de la surface
temps qui est dans l'air
et au contact de la surface il peut lui
arriver l'une des deux choses suivantes
il peut être capturée par un brin
d'herbe aveyronnais voilà donc ça c'est
la photosynthèse et en ce moment il sort
de l'atmosphère ou bien il peut se
dissoudre dans l'océan le citoyen n'a
assez peu en aveyron il peut se
dissoudre dans l'océan et ça c'est un
phénomène de vases communicants c'est à
dire que la coop comme la dissolution
s'il ya plus de place dans l'océan pour
mettre du co2 et que le co2 est à
l'étroit dans l'atmosphère il y en a une
partie qui passe de l'atmosphère dans
l'océan mais c'est un processus de vases
communicants et qui évidemment
réversible si à un moment il ya moins de
co2 dans l'atmosphère pour dieu sait
quelle raison est plus dans l'océan bas
ils peuvent sortir
c'est les processus qui sont très très
lent c'est processus de soustraction du
co2 à l'atmosphère parce qu'encore une
fois il faut revenir au contact de la
surface pour que ça se produise et alors
du coup le drame de notre affaire et
deux suivants
ici vous avez un graphique qui vous
représente la fraction du sûr plus de
co2 que nous avons mis dans l'atmosphère
qui est toujours dans l'atmosphère après
arrêt des émissions encore donc avec nos
émissions on a rajouté du co2 dans
l'atmosphère un jour on arrête quelle
qu'en soit la raison et à ce moment là
on regarde ce qu'est ce qui se passe
pour ce surplus de co2 et bien ce
graphique vous donne la réponse un
siècle après arrêt des émissions vous
avez 40 % du surplus de co2 qui est
toujours dans l'atmosphère
un millier d'années après arrêt des
émissions vous avez 20 à 30% du surplus
de co2 qui est toujours dans
l'atmosphère
et dix mille ans après l'arrêt des
émissions vous avez 10 à 15% du surplus
de co2 qui sera toujours dans
l'atmosphère
donc là je suis en train de vous dire
que l'état de l'atmosphère tel qu'il
était avant le début de l'utilisation
des combustibles fossiles est perdue à
jamais pour le temps qu'il reste à vivre
à l'humanité
plus jamais et à cause de ça la dérive
climatique qui en découle
est pour partie irréversibles aux mêmes
échelles de temps
donc je suis en train de vous dire que
le climat de l'an 2000 vous ne le
reverrez jamais et même le climat de
l'an 2020 il va disparaître et on ne le
reverra jamais
la dérive climatique à partir de
maintenant elle est pour toujours
le climat va être instable plus ou moins
pour ce qu'il reste à l'humanité à vivre
si on considère que l'humanité peut
encore vivre des bilans ce qui est
peut-être beaucoup je ne sais pas
alors bien évidemment là on est en train
de parler d'échec d'autant qu'ils sont
très très au delà des échelles de temps
à auquel on est habitué à raisonner à
l'échelle de temps déjà la plus longue à
laquelle on raisonne c'est d'autres vies
ou à la rigueur la vie de nos enfants
c'est très rare qu'on se projette sur
quatre générations et c'est surtout très
très au delà des échelles de temps qu'on
a l'habitude d'utiliser
quand on gère la collectivité des hommes
enfin la collectivité humaine
on est quand même habitué aujourd'hui à
raisonner au pas de temps de l'année de
quelques années un compte de résultat
d'une entreprise c'est une année
un mandat électif ces quelques années ma
stratégie de long terme dans une société
cotée ces trois ans les bonnes années
six mois les mauvaises donc voilà on est
quand même
très très habitués aujourd'hui à gérer
l'essentiel de ce qu'on fait sur des pas
de temps qu'ils sont très courts alors
que là il faudra recommencer à faire
comme colbert qui plantait des chaînes
pour qu un siècle et demi après on
puisse avoir des arbres avec lesquels
faire de la marine de guerre c'était
donc on est
il ya une asymétrie total entre l'étang
caractéristiques de cette affaire là et
il est temps caractéristiques de nos
modes de gestion aujourd'hui
alors parlons de coop comme quoi
ici alors donc comme le co2 a une durée
de vie très très longue dans
l'atmosphère enfin au surplus de co2 dit
très très longue dans l'atmosphère une
fois qu'il y ait est bien plus on
n'aimait plus la quantité de co2 dans
l'atmosphère au banc tu es ici vous avez
la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère qui
est gradué en partie par million en une
partie par million c'est un milite par
mètre cube pour que vous ayez une petite
idée
pas beaucoup et dont vous avez la
quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère alors
quasiment depuis l'année de ma naissance
depuis 1959 vous voyez au moment où je
suis né il y avait un peu moins de 320
millilitres par mètre cube dans la peur
enfin non je suis né un peu après 1950
bref allez y avait trois cent vingt
minutes par mètre cube de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
aujourd'hui on est quasiment à 420 c'est
à dire sans de plus à vous le dire c'est
pas beaucoup tout débute par mètre cube
on va voir si malheureusement ça fait
quand même beaucoup est ce que vous
voyez sur ce graphique c'est que
avant qu'ils aient des coop ça ça a
évolué exactement de la même manière qu
après qu elle écope exactement pareil
la cop16 lieu en
1995 s'il ya ici un suisse d'émigrer
est ce que vous savez dans quel pays tu
as eu lieu
la ministre de l'environnement car
c'était une femme qui a présidé la coop
1 et vous la connaissez tout
angela merkel absolument donc là copains
a eu lieu en allemagne et à l'époque
c'est en gala merkel qui l'a accueilli
en voyez c'est un gros succès c'est
l'année où la convention climat a été
ratifié par tous les pays et entre en
vigueur tant de succès d'accord regardez
ce qui se passe avant le relais ce qui
se passe après
brian protocole de kyoto qui est
toujours un gros succès puisqu'à ce
moment là les pays dits riches c'est à
dire les pays ocde près de l'engagement
de baisser leurs émissions en valeur
absolue voyez le résultat
après il ya eu copenhague où j'étais
qu'on a qualifié de gros échec bon après
y'a parier gros succès bon et glasgow
bon alors en fait il ya un énorme
malentendu avec les coop il ya un énorme
malentendu c'est que nous pensons que
les coptes devons être capables de
régler je ne sais pas où dans l'espace
international un problème dont on ne
s'occupe pas nous mêmes c'est une
chimère c'est une chimère
il n'y a pas de maître du monde ça
n'existe pas depuis le traité de
westphalie les états sont souverains il
n'y a pas de maître du monde
donc c'est une illusion de penser que
les coques vont régler ailleurs est pour
nous un problème que aujourd'hui nous
n'acceptons pas de régler ici et
maintenant
le problème se réglera ici et maintenant
et le jour où tous les pays du monde
auront réglé le problème ici et
maintenant alors les coop seront des
succès mais c'est bien en ce sens là que
ça se passe et donc la meilleure
conclusion je pas si vous connaissez ce
journal satirique s'appelle legault
raffy
gora fille avait fait un très très bon
résumé de la cop16
l'article tu auras fils était la cop16
s'engage à recycler les engagements de
la coupe 25
mai la faute c'est là l'autre c'est
celle de tous les citoyens consommateurs
du monde
qui aujourd'hui n'arrive pas à
s'organiser de telle sorte que leurs
représentants élus s'occupe sérieusement
du problème et on n'arrive pas à régler
nos propres contradictions
donc plus de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère la température de la
planète va s'élever alors de combien
on peut déjà commencer par regarder ce
qu'on a eu dans le passé alors sur cette
courbe voyez 1 0 sur l'échelle verticale
le zéro c'est la tempe c'est une
référence c'est une échelle relative
c'est la température moyenne de la
planète ce qu'on appelle la température
au sol parce que ce n'est pas partout la
même dans toute l'atmosphère donc c'est
la température moyenne de la planète
avant que on commence à cracher
significativement des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et en pratique c'est la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle qui sert
d'étalon d'accord donc vous prenez la
moyenne 19 1850 1901 sur toute l'année
sur toute la surface de la terre et vous
dites c'est ça la température moyenne de
la planète ce que vous voyez ci qu'à la
fin du xxème siècle donc en l'an 2000 on
a gagné à peu près 1 degrés par rapport
à cet étalon et alors on se parle là on
a gagné à peu près 1,1 1,2 degré par
rapport à cet étalon alors à 1,1 à 1,2
degré on a déjà 15% des coraux qui sont
morts on a déjà alors non pas à pas les
chiffres pour les éleveurs je pense pas
qu'ils aient beaucoup de décès chez les
bovins mais par contre vous avez eu déjà
en france sur les dernières années une
année où la récolte de patates a fait
moins 40% une année où le rhin a été le
doute ce pardon a été quasiment à sec
une année où le rhin a tellement baissé
que les bars je pouvais plus passer une
année où la récolte de blé fin de
céréales a fait moins je peux combien 20
à 30% vous avez au canada cette année la
récolte de blé dur qui a fait au moins
40 % vous avez la récolte sur un certain
nombre de productions fruitières cette
année qui va faire moins 50% et le gel
tardif est une conséquence directe du
réchauffement climatique la végétation
des bourgs plutôt au printemps les
épisodes de gel ont lieu au même moment
et crack vous pouvez dire adieu à la
production donc le 1,1 degré vous avez
déjà des espèces d'arbres en france qui
sont condamnés une partie des épicéas
rien qu'à un degré il va dès sont déjà
hors zone
hors zone de confort donc à 1,1 on se
dit bon c'est pas grand chose c'est il
ya déjà 50 degrés au canada il ya déjà
des jolies canicule il ya déjà eu l'été
2003 enfin voilà donc c'est quand même
pas complètement complètement
négligeable et alors pour l'avenir tout
dépend de ce qui va se passer au niveau
de nos émissions donc si on fait accords
de paris on reste sous les deux degrés
c'est la trajectoire qui est en bas et
si on y va à fond en charbon on est
plutôt sur la trajectoire du haut
un des points majeurs j'y reviendrai
après un des points majeurs qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que quand vous
regardez ce graphique vous voyez que
entre la fin de la courbe noire et vingt
ans plus tard les c2 les divers
scénarios sont très très peu
différenciés et en particulier à part le
scénario charbon adolphe auxquelles je
crois pas mais je vous dirai à la fin de
cette intervention pourquoi vous voyez
que tous les autres y est quasiment ils
sont superposées l'un sur l'autre sur
les 20 prochaines années ça veut dire
quoi cette histoire ça veut dire que
l'inertie du système est tel que à
partir du moment où on décide de
commencer à agir et où on le fait pour
de vrai eh bien on ne voit vraiment les
résultats de cette action que vingt ans
derrière je vais vous le dire autrement
changement climatique c'est une voiture
quand vous commencez à appuyer sur la
[ __ ] de frein
la première chose qui se passe c'est que
pendant les 20 ans qui suivent la
voiture accélère encore plus
c'est ça le changement climatique ce qui
veut dire que en même temps qu'eux on
est obligé de s'occuper de baisser les
émissions pour éviter que beaucoup plus
tard ça soit dramatique il faut pourtant
se préparer à un climat qui va continuer
à dériver et devenir moins sympathique
que celui qu'on connaissait on va devoir
faire les choses les deux en même temps
il va donc y avoir ce qu'on appelle
classiquement l'évitement les anglais
appellent ça mitigation et
l'adaptation pour autant qu'on puisse
s'adapter parce qu'il ya des trucs
auxquels on s'adaptera pas juste entre
des baffes
mais il va falloir faire les deux alors
voyez qu à la fin du siècle dans le
scénario charbon annoncent on a gagné 4
degrés par rapport à la températures
préindustrielles alors 4 degrés est ce
que c'est beaucoup ou pas beaucoup alors
pour le savoir pour faire un petit
retour dans le passé
vous avez ici une vision de ce à quoi
ressemblent les écosystèmes européens
alors quand je dis actuelle c'est plutôt
celle du 20è siècle mais peu importe les
écosystèmes du xxème siècle en europe si
on leur fiche la paix et qu'on les
supprime pas pour faire des pâturages
très utile et tout le reste très inutile
non si on les supprime pas pour faire
des cultures des routes de voile à des
fins tous que tout ce que les hommes ont
fait à la place de là où il y avait des
écosystèmes vous voyez qui a
essentiellement des forêts donc en gros
ce qui pousse spontanément les
écosystèmes à léquilibre j'ai envie de
dire en europe si on leur fiche la paix
c'est essentiellement des écosystèmes
forestiers
à l'est c'est trop sec au nord c'est
trop froid et trop sec
voici l'europe il ya vingt mille ans il
ya vingt mille ans nous sommes au coeur
de la dernière ère glaciaire parce que
dans le cadre des variations spontanée
du climat parce qu'évidemment le climat
varie sans âme pour le tripoter un juste
les variations sont pas aussi rapides et
bien il ya vingt mille ans l'europe est
au coeur de la dernière un glacier enfin
la terre est au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire il est beaucoup plus froid et
le paysage est un peu différent d'abord
vous d'exporter pas de roquefort chez
les suédois et pas deux suédois ils sont
ceux trois kilomètres de glace ce que
vous n'exportait pas plus de roquefort
chez les canadiens car les canadiens
sens ou trois kilomètres de glace aussi
vous avez des calottes monstrueuse
énorme qui recouvre tout le nord de
l'europe là le canada le nord de la
russie est par contre je sais que dans
le sud-ouest le rugby c'est important là
j'ai une bonne nouvelle vous voyez que
les écossais les irlandais sont sous la
glace d'irlandais surtout j'ai coincé on
arrive à les battre mais
voilà donc vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
de glace qui recouvre une partie de
l'europe du nord alors ce gros glaçon
est constituée d'eau l'eau il a bien
fallu la prendre quelque part l épave
d'une mars est en fait l'eau a été prise
dans l'océan il ya que dans l'océan on
veut prendre suffisamment d'eau pour
faire des gros glacier de trois
kilomètres d'épaisseur et comme le fond
de l'océan est toujours au même endroit
1 le niveau de l'océan a baissé de 120 m
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui connaît
cette histoire on peut rentrer à pied
dans la grotte cosquer qui aujourd'hui
est une grotte où on rentre en plongée
l'entrée est à 27 mètres sous l'eau
après un espèce de boyaux ascendant et
la sortie du boyau est au dessus du
niveau de l'eau et donc il ya des
peintures comme balasko des des
peintures antique qui sont dans une
grotte dont l'entrée sous marine
et donc a pas de réussite donc monsieur
barnier à la ville tranquille puisque
vous voyez il ya une continuité
territoriale entre ce qui reste de la
grande-bretagne qui n'est pas sous la
glace et le
et la france
il fait beaucoup plus froid donc il fait
beaucoup plus sec il ne vous aura pas
échappé que l'hiver quand il fait très
froid c'est rare qu'ils fassent qui est
énorme précipitation quand il fait très
froid en général il fait très très sec
tout simplement parce qu'il ya peu d'eau
qui peut s'évaporer dans un air très
froid et donc les précipitations en
europe sont beaucoup plus faible
qu'aujourd'hui est par ailleurs le
climat est beaucoup plus rude c'est
beaucoup plus froid et donc les
écosystèmes installés en europe sont
beaucoup plus maigre et les quelques
chasseurs de mammouths et cueilleurs
d'airelles que nous trouvons à l'époque
sont par exemple au nombre de cent mille
en france
donc la population française compte à
peu près cent mille âmes donc je pense
que la veyron pas beaucoup
à ce moment là c'est tout ce que un
écosystème maigrichon comme celui qu'on
a à cette époque peut nourrir d'hommes
alors quand on est passé de l'état de
gauche à l'état de droite en ce qui
concerne l'europe ça s'est opérée dans
le cadre d'un réchauffement global de la
planète
et en tant qu elle eu lieu pour des
raisons parfaitement naturel et ce
réchauffement global il est de l'ordre
de 4 à 5 degrés en dix mille ans
donc là vous voyez le résultat d'une
expérience grandeur nature qui a été
fait par la planète terre pour nous dans
le passé c'est se réchauffer de dix
mille ans de 4 à 5 degrés pardon andy
bilan vous voyez l'ampleur de la
modification que ça engendre
oui l'ampleur de la modification que ça
engendre alors pour comprendre que là on
n'est pas du tout en train de parler de
la même chose je vais vous le dire d'une
autre manière vous avez ici toujours
avec le même 0 de référence la
température moyenne de la planète sur
les vingt mille dernières années
évidemment j'en ai caché une partie
sinon ces spoilers
et vous voyez là la température pour
commencer qui a eu entre 8000 ans avant
la naissance de monsieur jesus christ et
2000 ans après donc les dix mille
dernières années et vous voyez que cette
température n est pas exactement stable
mais elle a varié d'une fraction de
degrés seulement elle varie d'une
fraction de degrés seulement et c'est ce
qui nous a permis d'être dans cette
salle car la stabilité climatique des
dix mille dernières années correspond
comme par hasard à la sédentarisation
des hommes vous savez que la fin de la
préhistoire c'est ya dix mille ans c'est
à dire il ya dix mille ans nous sortons
d'une civilisation de chasseurs
cueilleurs nomades se déplaçant au créé
des endroits où on arrivait à manger
suffisamment pour survivre et faire
quelques enfants à une civilisation où
c'est plus nécessaire de se balader au
cours du temps puisque au cours du temps
le climat reste constant et donc on peut
commencer à développer une agriculture
et à la perfectionner au fil des
civilisations
processus dont nous sommes les lointains
héritiers
alors avant il ya la déglaciation la
voici donc on passe des mammouths au
salers ou aubrac
et après voilà ce qui s'est passé au
cours du 20e siècle
et voilà ce qui pourrait se passer au
cours du 21e siècle avec là on n'est
même pas dans le scénario charbon à donf
on est dans un scénario dans lequel
allez on va dire on racle jusqu'au fond
les réserves de pétrole et de gaz
et le charbon pas de pas la totalité
vous voyez qu'on est en train de parler
de quelque chose de considérablement
plus brutale alors je vais reprendre le
parallèle de ma voiture vous avez deux
manières de passer de 100 km/heure à 0
km heure en voiture la première c'est de
le faire en cas de seconde j'ai secoué
mais vous êtes vivant
la deuxième manière c'est de le faire en
quatre centièmes de seconde à vous êtes
mort
vous êtes un peuple at-il donc
c'est exactement la même chose quand on
parle du climat entre 4 degrés en dix
mille ans et 4 degrés en un siècle on
est on peut prendre exactement le même
parallèle exactement le même parallèle
très clairement je vais maintenant vous
détailler quelques conséquences mais
très clairement une transition de cette
ampleur à cette vitesse vous pouvez
retenir que ça sera le bazar partout et
notamment probablement la guerre partout
mais au sens premier du terme c'est que
les gens vont se taper dessus
c'est très exactement ça qui nous
attends je pense si on met de
l'expérience à son terme alors
maintenant je vais vous donner quelques
détails
un certain nombre d'entre vous
probablement lui certain nombre de
choses sur le climat dans le journal je
vous fiche mon billet que tout ce que je
vais vous raconter maintenant vous
l'avez quasiment jamais lu dans le
journal qui ne cesse de dire on risque
4° montrait bien aux messieurs 4° vont
très bien on région 4° montrait bien on
risque un cadeau afin donc en fait ça
veut dire quoi
alors voilà une première conséquence ici
vous avez une publication qui est sorti
il ya quelques années et qui donne le
nombre de jours par an où il n'est pas
possible de rester à l'extérieur sans
mourir
dans un climat qui se serait réchauffer
alors non pas de 4 mai de 5 degrés par
rapport à l'époque préindustrielle donc
de 4 degrés par rapport à maintenant
donc c'est vraiment très très haut
alors pourquoi est ce que les gens
meurent parce que vous voyez que ça
concerne avant tout la zone équatoriale
donc la zone équatoriale est une zone
qui est humide et c'est un endroit où
l'air est souvent saturé d'humidité un
air saturé d'humidité ça veut dire que
il contient déjà toute l'eau qui peut
contenir et vous ne pouvez plus mettre
de l'eau supplémentaires dedans et ça
veut dire en particulier que si vous
êtes dans ce genre d'atmosphère vous ne
pouvez pas transpiré pour évacuer votre
chaleur parce que la transpiration c'est
l'évaporation de la sueur à la surface
de votre peau et si vous pouvez pas
évaporée d'aubin vous pouvez pas
transpiré et si dans ce genre d'endroit
il fait plus que la température de votre
peau si en plus de 35 degrés et bien
vous pouvez pas vous refroidir en
rayonnant de la chaleur puisque la leyre
et puis au bout et vous pouvez pas vous
refroidir en transpirant puisque l'air
est plus vite que vous et donc vous
mourrez d'hyperthermie
et vous voyez que dans un monde qui se
serait réchauffé de 4 degrés par rapport
à aujourd'hui il ya allait à peu près
deux milliards d'individus l'asie du
sud-est l'inde qui se retrouvent dans
des endroits où plus de la moitié de
l'année vous ne pouvez pas travailler en
extérieur et en particulier vous pouvez
pas avoir d'agriculture alors vous
comprenez bien que plus on ira vers ce
genre de situation plus ces gens là vont
se dire on va pas rester où on est on va
bouger alors ils bougeront pas
nécessairement beaucoup 50 km 100 km 200
300 m'enfin de proche en proche ça
suffit pour déstabiliser les régions et
la voilà à premiers motifs pour lesquels
les gens pourraient facilement se taper
dessus parce que les flux migratoires
seront excessive est supérieur aux
capacités d'accueil
cette élévation de température elle ne
va pas se faire de manière homogène en
ce qui concerne les vagues de chaleur
c'est à dire que un degré de plus c'est
pas un degré de plus toute l'année
partout et tout le temps nuit et jour
hiver comme été et c est en particulier
ça va aller beaucoup plus vite sur les
extrêmes de température
ici vous avez un graphique qui vient du
dernier rapport du giec et qui vous dit
que un événement qui actuellement 20
actuellement dans la période
pré-industrielle plus exactement dans la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle arrivait
tous les dix ans avec un réchauffement à
4 degrés il arrivera neuf fois sur dix
enfin neuf années sur dix ça sera plus
chaud que cette phase on aura cet
événement décennale ou plus est en fait
le maximum de température qui sera
atteint à cette occasion pour être de 5
degrés supérieures à ce que c'était dans
le l'époque préindustrielle
donc les canicules seront neuf fois plus
fréquentes et la température maximale
atteinte
éventuellement 5 degrés plus élevées
et en ce qui concerne les canicules qui
n'avait lieu qu'une fois tous les 50 ans
et bien dans un monde à 4 degrés sarrail
40 fois plus souvent
avec là aussi une température qui est 5
degrés plus élevées donc ça veut dire
que les extrêmes de température vont
augmenter beaucoup plus vite
les épisodes caniculaires plus
exactement vont se multiplier beaucoup
plus vite que l'élévation de température
ça va pas être proportionnelle à
l'élévation de température ça va
augmenter beaucoup plus vite que ça
deuxième chose qui va se passer c'est
que les saisons hausse modifié alors je
vais pas commenter ce graphique en
détail parce qu'il vous donne
l'allongement et où le rétrécissement
des saisons donc ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que toujours dans le scénario à 4
degrés l'été passerait de trois à six
mois
l'hiver de trois à un mois en gros seins
et l'automne et le printemps perdrait
chacun un mois
après dans un scénario à deux degrés
c'est moins marqué mais c'est le même
c'est le même
le même esprit
une élévation de température ça modifie
le cycle de l'eau vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure dans un climat qui se réchauffe
l'évaporation va avoir tendance à
s'intensifier parce que la surface de la
planète étant plus chaude est par
ailleurs l'air est en plus chaud il peut
emmener plus de vapeur d'eau est donc
enfin il peut emporter plus de vapeur
d'eau donc l'évaporation va avoir
tendance à augmenter et donc ça veut
dire que les précipitations vont avoir
tendance à augmenter aussi donc un
climat globalement plus chaud est un
climat globalement plus pluvieux mais ça
sera pas plus de pluie partout et tout
le temps et sous la même forme ce que
vous voyez ici c'est un certain nombre
de zones où il va pas pleuvoir plus mais
il va pleuvoir - et vous voyez que
malheureusement pour nous une partie des
endroits il va pleuvoir - c'est le sud
le sud de l'europe là tout le pourtour
du bassin méditerranéen
c'est un endroit où dans le cadre du
réchauffement climatique il est anticipé
et c'est malheureusement déjà en cours
que les précipitations au ps c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle
l'eau c'est quand même la vie
ça ne va pas empêcher l'augmentation des
épisodes pluvieux intenses
et là aussi plus le climat se
réchauffera plus les épisodes pluvieux
intenses de viendront nombreux et alors
vous pouvez très bien avoir plus de
pluie plus mal répartie auquel cas
j'espère ne pas être contredit par les
agriculteurs dans cette salle ça fait
pas votre affaire
parce que quand il pleut énormément va
tout s'en va ça reste pas dans le sol
pierce à ravine donc des fois de temps
en temps ça en porte une partie de la du
sol notamment pour le quand les seuls
sons du leader et à ce moment
donc vous pouvez avoir la même quantité
de pluie dans l'année sauf qu'elle tombe
à un moment où une partie russell très
rapidement et vous vous retrouvez quand
même à l'arrivée avec des sols plus sec
est en fait c'est exactement ce qui va
se passer dans un nombre croissant de
régions dans le monde ici vous avez
l'évolution de l'humidité des sols dans
un monde qui s'est réchauffée de 2
degrés est ce que vous voyez c'est que
énormément de pays des moyennes
latitudes on des sols qui s'assèchent
c'est le cas pour toute l'europe c'est
le cas en fait pour tout pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen c'est le cas pour
l'europe centrale c'est le cas pour
l'amérique du nord c'est le cas autre
mauvaise nouvelle pour l'amazonie pour
une bonne partie de l'amérique du sud
c'est le cas pour la chine c'est le cas
pour l'asie du sud est
donc vous voyez et ça c'est parce que
encore une fois d'une part l'appui et de
plus mal répartie et d'autre part il n'y
a pas que la pluie qui augmente il ya
aussi l'évaporation qui augmente si
climat est plus chaud
or ce qui compte pour les végétaux c'est
bien l'humidité du sol c'est bien ça qui
compte pour faire en sorte que les
végétaux se porte bien
ça plus le stress hydrique des plantes
plus le stress thermique parce qu'il ya
un stress thermique qui peut s'appliquer
aux végétaux également fait que vous
allez avoir une pression sur les
écosystèmes qui va globalement leur être
néfaste à peu près partout et tout le
temps au premier rang ici vous avez un
graphique alors j'attends avec
impatience enfin non pas avec impatience
ce n'est pas une bonne nouvelle mais
le l'équivalent dans le rapport du giec
qui va sortir dans pas longtemps l'année
prochaine sur les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique donc ça c'était
la dernière édition en 2014 mais vous
voyez l'évolution des rendements
agricoles dans le monde donc là le 0 de
référence et les rendements actuels est
ce que vous voyez c'est que les
rendements agricoles ils vont baisser
quel que soit le type de région là les
régions tropicales et là les régions
tempérées et quelles que soient les
mesures d'adaptation qu'on pourrait
prendre ou pas c'est à dire que le
changement climatique est plus puissant
que les mesures d'adaptation qu'on peut
prendre dans la quasi totalité des cas
est ce que vous voyez c'est que les
rendements agricoles il devrait perdre 2
% en gros par décennie à cause du
changement climatique alors ça peut
aller plus vite que ça dans un certain
nombre d'endroits et en fait ce genre
d'étude on s'est rendu compte entre ces
dernières années qu'elle était plutôt
conservatrice malheureusement parce
qu'elle ne tenait pas compte d'un
certain nombre d'effets d'amplification
qu'on peut avoir par exemple sur les
ravageurs c'est extrêmement difficile de
faire des projections à long terme
savoir comment est-ce que le scolyte va
se comporter sur l'épicéa 50 ans
compliqué il suffit d'une poussée
particulièrement violentes et pitt façon
les arbres sont morts et donc ce qui va
se passer dans 50 ans n'est plus un
problème parce qu'à 30 ans qui sont
dehors
donc le voilà ce genre de ce genre de
projection ça reste des choses qui sont
fragiles par contre ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que la tendance à long
terme elle est adverse
là vous avez un exemple plus précis
c'est une analyse qu'on a dû faire à
carbonne quatre cantons à pour un client
et on a regardé avec les données météo
le nombre d'épisodes où il y avait trois
jours en juin où la température monte au
dessus de 25 degrés trois jours
consécutifs parce qu'il se trouve que en
l'occurrence pour les cultures qu'on a
regardé ça à baisser les rendements et
bien vous voyez que dans le climat de la
fin du xxème siècle ça n'arrive pas et à
2050 avec un scénario un temps ci alors
à 2035 en fait on a mis deux scénarios
intensifs mais quel que soit le scénario
c'est le même résultat parce que je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de
différence entre un scénario à 20 ans
et à 2050 avec un scénario intensifs et
ça serait presque pareil avec un
scénario qu'il qu'il est moins vous
voyez qu'il ya une bonne partie des
des zones la danse est dans cette région
où vous avez ce genre d'épisode deux
fois par an enfin entre une et deux fois
par an donc tous les ans vous êtes à peu
près sûr de l'avoir
sur les écosystèmes en fait le début de
changement climatique a déjà commencé à
exercer aussi un effet de pression
important cette carte elle a un code
couleur vous avez deux cartes une en or
présente la situation avant 2000 et en
basset après 2000 fin 1999
et le code couleur est le suivant si le
code couleur et vert ça veut dire que
année après année la photosynthèse
augmente dit autrement année après année
les écosystèmes répondent à
l'augmentation du co2 augmentation de la
température en croissant plus vite
photosynthèse augmente nonobstant le
fait qu'il peut y avoir éventuellement
des variations précipitation et quand le
code couleur et rouge ça veut dire que
année après année la photosynthèse
baisse donc les écosystèmes ont toujours
une photosynthèse sont toujours vivants
mais ça veut dire que année après année
ils sont de moins en moins vigoureux
c'est ça que ça veut dire eh bien vous
voyez que en 2000 il ya un certain
nombre de zones où la situation a déjà
basculé et là il s'agit que de la
photosynthèse
il s'agit même pas de la destruction
d'écosystèmes à cause des incendies qui
vient se rajouter par dessus
donc ce que vous voyez c'est qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'écosystèmes qui
commence déjà à souffrir du
réchauffement climatique le stress
hydrique et de stress thermique est déjà
suffisant pour que dès à présent
le leur vigueur ce soit inversée et donc
il était de plus en plus vigoureux
puisqu'on était au début du
réchauffement c'est plutôt pas mal et la
maintenance est en train de s'inverser
si je reviens l'agriculture vous avez
ici un graphique qui a été publiée par
le giec en 2019 et qui vous donne la
sévérité des conséquences pour un
certain nombre de conséquences c'est en
anglais mais je vais m'intéresser qu'à
ça pour un certain nombre de
conséquences et le code couleur il est
toujours le même en broutards de là vous
êtes dans des conséquences qui sont
locales est gérable et quand vous passez
dans le pourpre vous êtes dans le global
et pas gérable est ce que vous voyez
c'est que à 2,5 degrés de réchauffement
c'est la barre de droite qui m'intéresse
l'insécurité alimentaire
devient généralisée et probablement pas
gérable alors pour tous ceux d'entre
vous qui se souviennent de leurs cours
d'histoire la disette c'est un très très
bon facteur de déstabilisation politique
ça fait sauter les régimes comme qui
rigole c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé au moment de la révolution
française c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé au moment du printemps arabe là je
pense que dans cette salle vous le savez
un le printemps arabe ça a été des
émeutes de la faim à cause d'une
inflation alimentaire totalement
intolérables donc là ce que je suis
c'est pour ça que le titre de cette
planche
j'espère mauvaise blague peut-être pas à
partir du moment où les gens qui ont
l'habitude d'avoir à manger commence à
avoir des vrais problèmes d'accès à
l'alimentation eh bien on peut attendre
des choses qui sont pas nécessairement
très sympathique
il y avait il ya quelques jours un
article de géo qui expliquait qu entre
les incendies de cette année qui a eu en
californie usa il ya eu des incendies
absolument monstrueux et les incendies
qui a eu les années précédentes en
californie où il y avait déjà eu des
incendies absolument monstrueux il ya
probablement 20% des séquoias géants qui
sont déjà morts
en france vous avez ici une carte qui
vous donne le degré d'inflammabilité des
forêts donc le risque d'incendié
dans encore une fois la fin du xxème
siècle et le début du 21e c'est la
période de référence tout à gauche et
comment ça a évolué au cours du temps
avec un scénario intensifs alors
l'horizon proche je le rappelle est
indépendant du scénario donc ce que vous
voyez c'est que dans l'horizon proche
vous avez déjà un certain nombre de
régions dans le nord de la france qui
sont inflammables comme la réal et le on
va dire le haut de la vallée du rhône
aujourd'hui et si vous allez à 2050 où
déjà les scénarios commencent à se
différencier un peu mais pas tant que ça
eh bien vous voyez qu'en 2050 vous avez
aussi des régions du centre qui
deviennent alors là pour le coup
inflammables comme l'arrière pays
méditerranéen aujourd'hui
ces régions là là qui sont des régions
boisées sont inflammables comme
l'arrière pays méditerranéen
aujourd'hui et en 2000 s'en va c'est une
bonne partie de la france alors vous
faites partie des chanceux voilà les
astérix de l' incendie
mais sinon vous voyez qu'une bonne
partie de la france
en gros et inflammables comme l'arrière
pays méditerranéen
aujourd'hui et alors évidemment les gros
seins sans dire il suffit d'une fois
puis après il y en a pas d'autres parce
que toute façon la forêt à brûler
les phénomènes extrêmes vont
s'intensifier ils vont pas
nécessairement se multiplier en nombre
par contre ils vont devenir plus
vigoureux alors la raison à cela elle
tient à ce que la petite animation sur
le réchauffement climatique que je vous
ai montré au début je vous ai dit la
température près du sol augmente dans le
cadre du réchauffement climatique mais
comme le rayonnement terrestre il est
capté plus vigoureusement près du sol
quand il ya plus d effet de serre du
coup il y en a moins pour être captée
par la haute atmosphère et en
particulier la stratosphère
dans le cadre du réchauffement
climatique la température au sol
augmente mais la température de la
stratosphère diminue ce qui veut dire
que l'écart de température entre le sol
et la stratosphère augmente et cet écart
de température
c'est lui qui engendre les mouvements
convectifs de l'air qui met en route les
phénomènes extrêmes alors quand ce
mouvement convectifs à lui au dessus de
l'océan tropicale ça s'appelle un
ouragan et quand il a lieu au dessus de
la terre les thés s'appelle un orage
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des orages l'été
et pas l'hiver parce que la température
d'à stratosphère est à peu près la même
toute l'année par contre la température
au sol est beaucoup plus élevé l'été
donc la différence de température est
beaucoup plus importante et donc ça fait
des mouvements convectifs qui sont
beaucoup plus forts et peau s'il ya des
gens qui font planeur dans cette salle
ils le savent très bien des courants
ascendants des cumulonimbus sont des
courants particulièrement puissants
donc les phénomènes extrêmes vont être
mis en route par un moteur qui sera plus
puissant et donc ils vont devenir plus
intense ça veut dire que les ouragans
vont avoir des précipitations des
maximums de précipitations plus élevé là
aussi je sais pas si vous avez suivi
l'actualité récente et ya un ouragan qui
s'appelle dida qui est passé sur new
york ya pas longtemps et bien les
records de pluie qui ont été enregistrés
dans l'état de new york il ya eu des
précipitations sur trois heures qui
était quasiment du double du record
précédent du double
donc les précipitations intenses vont
augmenter dans le cadre des ouragans et
les vents intense la force maximale des
vents va augmenter également on observe
également ces dernières années des
ouragans qui s'intensifie à une vitesse
extrêmement enfin jamais vu auparavant
c'est à dire qu'en l'espace de 24 heures
il passe de catégorie 1 à la catégorie 5
quoi ça c'est pareil c'est des trucs qui
se voyait pas avant
le niveau de l'eau va monter sur l'océan
bon là ça vous allez dire ça vous
concerne pas vous êtes très au dessus de
l'océan vous allez voir si ça vous
conseille quand même
pourquoi donc le niveau de l'eau va
monter alors pourquoi est-ce que le
niveau de l'eau va monter parce que
quand vous chauffer l'eau et se dilate
et donc quand vous chauffer l'eau c'est
en surface dans le cadre du
réchauffement climatique 20 lots se
dilate et le niveau de l'eau monte et
puis la deuxième chose qui fait monter
le niveau de l'eau c'est la fonte de
tous les glaçons qui sont posées sur
terre donc à la fois la mer de glace et
les calotte antarctique et groenlandaise
est alors en fait c'est les calotte
antarctique et groenlandaise qui recèle
l'incertitude maximale et le risque
maximal à long terme le groenland a déjà
commencé à fondre et à partir de
maintenant les mouvements la dynamique
de cette fonte fait que elle va
continuer au cours du temps quoi qu'on
fasse donc même si on arrête les
émissions de bain matin il continue à
fondre
l'antarctique est également devenu un
contributeur à la hausse du niveau de la
mer pendant longtemps on n'a pas su et
en particulier il ya un gros point
d'interrogation sur ce qu'on appelle
l'antarctique de l'ouest où là vous avez
un glacier émissaire qui est en train de
fiche le camp rapidement vers la mer
alors l'antarctique de l'ouest c'est
quoi c'est un château de cartes de
glaciers qui sont arc boutés les uns sur
les autres et l'ensemble est posée sur
un socle rocheux qui est sous marins
donc c'est un édifice qui est un peu
instable et si les classiers sert là ce
qui se déversent dans la mer commence à
être déstabilisé parce que la mer qui se
réchauffe et qui montrent bien les
grignoter par le bas eh bien il pourrait
fiche le camp à vitesse accélérée dans
la mer et l'ensemble de l'édifice
déstabiliser l'ensemble de la calotte se
désagrège et fiche le camp dans la mer
alors évidemment ça passerait en une
semaine mais les dernières publications
scientifiques disent que à l'échelle de
1 ou quelques siècles c'est pas
impossible et c'est comme dans les
contrats d'assurance quand vous
regardiez le graphique du giec on vous
donne l augmentation du niveau de la mer
donc l'augmentation du niveau de la mer
et en bas là sur ce graphique jusqu'en
2100 on du bruit pour beaucoup puis là
vous lisez les petits caractères pour
2300 et vous lisez les petits caractères
en eau et vous lisez ses
alors je peux vous dire que en aveyron
en 2300 si la mer est monté de 15 mètres
vous allez le voir passer aussi parce
qu'il a plus un port
et vous en dépendent et tous ceux
d'entre vous qui importe des aliments
vous avez besoin des ports il ya plus de
centrales électriques de bord de mer ou
charbon du client sans vous non plus
donc vous avez un tout petit sujet même
en avion avec la hausse du niveau de la
mer nous avons tous un sujet avec la
hausse du niveau de la mer parce que la
mondialisation dépens de la côte
même s'il ya plus de mondialisation du
tout on dépend de la côte aussi pour
tout un tas de trucs
ça va évidemment engendré quelques
mouvements de population donc vous avez
ici ce à quoi ressemble le trait de côte
du nord de l'europe avec une mère qui
serait monté de 9 m non pas de 15 mètres
mais 9 m voilà donc hambourg fin de
hambourg pour ceux qui aiment pas le
hareng c'est une bonne nouvelle
fin de
voilà les belges et les wallons et les
flamands ont intérêt à bien s'entendre
puisque les premiers vont devoir
accueillir les seconds voilà enfin même
en avant d'en arriver là c'est évident
qu'on aura des que cynthia répétition
avec parce que c'est comme ça que ça va
se passer la hausse du niveau de l'océan
c'est que vous avez les infrastructures
de bord de mer les logements les
centrales les ports les terminaux
ferroviaires les silos lorsque vous
voulez qu'ils se rapprochent
progressivement du niveau de l'eau et
puis à l'occasion d'un phénomène extrême
comme il y en a toujours eu même s'il
n'augmente pas en intensité pof la mer
franchi les défenses et va faire des
dégâts derrière c'est comme ça que ça va
se manifester les conséquences de la
hausse du niveau de la mer s'est pas de
façon continue comme la baraque qui
monte puis on remonte la serviette
vous avez tous entendu parler du gulf
stream alors en fait le gulf stream
c'est pas lui qui réchauffe l'europe le
gulf stream est un courant qui boucle au
niveau des tropiques ce qui réchauffe
l'europe c'est une branche qui s'échappe
du gulf stream et qui s'appelle la
dérive nord atlantique
cette dérive nord atlantique vient
mourir au sud du groenland où l'eau
plonge à cause d'un phénomène je
répondrai aux questions s'il y en a je
vais pas vous le décrire en détail
cette dérive nord atlantique est
extrêmement puissante
alors moi qui suis parisien donc chauvin
parisiens n'ont pas jusque je connais
juste débit de ce fleuve le débit de la
seine à paris ces quelques centaines de
mètres cubes à la seconde le débit du
rhône à son as on a faim quand vous êtes
au printemps là que la neige fond etc
c'est un peu plus de mille mètres cubes
à la seconde
la dérive nord atlantique son débit ces
25 millions de mètres cubes à la seconde
costaud et là vous avez alors un million
de mètres cubes à la seconde ça
s'appelle un ce ver trucs
et le code csv alors ici vous voyez la
baisse de cette dérive nord atlantique
qui est envisagée pour le 21e siècle
vous voyez que important de 25 on perd 5
à 10 et vous voyez que c'est
raisonnablement indépendant du scénario
dit autrement la très grande part
d'incertitude elle vient dé
l'incertitude de modélisation elle vient
pas de l'incertitude du scénario
et cet affaiblissement a déjà commencé
et la question que tout le monde se pose
c'est est-ce que pourrait s'arrêter
brusquement
processus qui a déjà eu lieu dans le
passé
la dernière fois au cours d'un épisode
qui s'est appelé le dryas récent dans le
cadre de la dernière déglaciation alors
si je pourrai répondre si les questions
que vous avez
la réponse est probablement pas au cours
du 21e siècle après c'est pas
complètement impossible si ça se
produisait évidemment ça ne supprimerait
pas le réchauffement climatique global
ça ne supprimerait même pas le
réchauffement moyen en europe par contre
ça nous rapprocherait probablement des
conditions des canadiens de la côte est
c'est à dire avec des saisons
considérablement plus marquée que en
l'absence de cette dérive
le fait qu'une partie du co2 qu'on met
dans l'atmosphère repasse dans l'océan
rend ce dernier - alcalin c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'acidification de l'océan et ça
ça empêche les petites bêtes qui doivent
synthétiser du calcaire de bien se
porter
je vous fait grâce d'autres conséquences
encore l'augmentation de la biodiversité
microbienne et notamment de la
biodiversité des agents pathogènes il ya
un certain nombre d'agents pathogènes
vous avez en général quand on chauffe le
bouillon de culture les petites bêtes
aime bien ça donc on va avoir une
multiplication d'agents pathogènes
nouveau donc le coc vide normalement
c'est pas ça mais il y aura un comique
du climat il y en a peut-être déjà radio
france aura jamais attribué les causes
dont vous aurez ça aussi et alors en
bout de course hier nous nous on peut
donc dans cette affaire souffrir de
plein de manières différentes
et par ailleurs comme on fait
l'expérience pour la première fois
absolument personne ne peut vous faire
un inventaire très précis des
conséquences en vous disant à 1.52
degrés de réchauffement je prévois que
la récolte de fourrage en aveyron aura
baissé de 58 % très exactement
personne va vous faire un truc comme ça
ça n'existe pas
donc tout ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on
navigue dans un univers qui devient de
plus en plus volatile est de plus en
plus risqué et personne n'est capable de
vous échéance est précisément et de vous
quantifier précisément les claques qu'on
va prendre
c'est toute la difficulté de ce problème
donc on doit répondre avec des efforts
certains parce que si je vous dis
maintenant il ya 20 % de vos impôts qui
vont passer dans la résolution de ce
problème c'est un effort certain savait
tout de suite que ça vous coûte je ne
suis pas capable de vous dire si ça
gagne au bout d'une semaine de 15 jours
d'un mois de deux mois de six mois d'un
an de 15 ans de 20 ans de 50
c'est toute la difficulté du sujet c'est
toute la difficulté du sujet on sait
qu'on est en train de jouer avec le feu
au sens premier du terme mais on sait
pas quand est ce qu'on va s'en prendre
une énorme sur la tête qui fait qu'on se
dira comme petit gibus 1 si j'avais su
j'aurais pas venu
ce qu'on sait par contre c'est quelle
est l'ampleur de l'effort à faire si on
veut limiter le réchauffement à une
valeur donnée donc on ne sait pas faire
correspondre à une valeur du
réchauffement une baffe précise un
instant précis à un endroit précis on
sait on sait donner des directions
générales qui sont celles que je vous ai
donné
d'autre j'aurais pu vous donner si
j'avais été en indice je vous aurais dit
la mousson va s'intensifier j'aurais pu
vous dire ça aussi
par contre on sait relier le
l'élévation de température à la quantité
totale de co2 qu'on met dans
l'atmosphère et parce que ça on la
physique nous dit que c'est à peu près
linéaire donc ici vous avez une courbe
qui vous donne l'élévation de
température planétaire en fonction de la
quantité totale de co2 qu'on aimait dans
l'atmosphère
enfin 2020 on avait émis à peu près de
1300 milliards de tonnes de co2 et la
température est montée d'un peu plus
d'un degré 1,1 en accords de paris vous
dis 1,5 corps alors on va jouer 1,5
alors le 5 scélérat et donc si on veut
respecter l'accord de paris ça veut dire
que d'ici à la fin du 21e siècle
on ne peut pas émettre plus de 3000
milliards de tonnes en totale en cumulé
mais dont 2300 ont déjà été émises donc
ça veut dire qu'il nous aurait 700 à
émettre donc dans les 80 ans qui
viennent on a collectivement les humains
sur cette planète 700 milliards de
tonnes à émettre alors que sur les
décennies passées parce que l'essentiel
a été crachées depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale on en a craché
2300 alors je vais vous le dire
autrement ça veut dire qu'un bébé qui
naît aujourd'hui si on respecte l'accord
de paris son droit et mettre au cours de
sa vie c'est le dixième du droit et
maître de ses grands-parents qui meurent
aujourd'hui
c'est ça que ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'une personne qui à 80
ans aujourd'hui en moyenne sur terre a
émis 10 fois plus que ce que mon bébé
qui naît aujourd'hui aura droit
d'émettre au cours de sa vie
c'est ça d'accord de paris alors
maintenant vous comprenez pourquoi c'est
illusoire d'attendre des cop qu'ils
allaient régler le problème à notre
place
ils ne le feront pas à notre place donc
ils vous disent d'accord ouais ok ils
disent qu'ils veulent mais ils le font
pas nous enfin je veux dire on peut le
faire c'est pas la coop qu'il fera la
place et si on veut limiter le
réchauffement à 2 degrés qui est une
valeur que vous avez probablement vu
passer aussi est bien là même motif même
punition mais plutôt aux alentours de
3000 5 et là mon bébé très bonne
nouvelle au lieu d'avoir le dixième il a
le sixième est ce que quelqu'un qui à 80
ans a émis sur sa vie
même en se limitant à deux degrés c'est
donc un effort absolument titanesque qui
passe notamment par le fait que les
émissions sont divisées par trois au
moins entre maintenant et le moment où
mes enfants rom on nage
dans 30 ans
alors une division par trois et après on
va commencer à entrer dans le un peu
dans les détails une division par trois
ça veut dire une baisse de 5% par an en
pratique un serrage donc si vous si vous
regardez ce que ça veut dire de diviser
par trois en trente ans ça veut dire
qu'en gros il faut baisser les émissions
de 5 % par an il se trouve que 5% de
baisse sur une année c'est ce qu'on a eu
dans le monde l'année 2020
2025 pour cent donc si on veut résoudre
le problème du changement climatique
aujourd'hui on cherche pas du tout à
faire redémarrer l'économie on cherche à
se prendre acolytes de plus sur la
figure
et puis non parce que l'économie
redémarrerait et puis l'économie ne
redémarre en toujours pas rester au même
niveau on sent reprend un de plus sur la
figure l'année d'après et c'est moins 5
% tous les ans par rapport à l'année
précédente voilà c'est ça les deux
degrés de l'accord de paris c'est ça
alors vous comprenez qu'il va falloir un
peu plus que de voter pour un candidat
écolo présidentielle pour y arriver en
gros ça veut dire quelque part quelque
chose qui ressemble à une économie de
guerre ça veut dire que on considère que
cet effort là est tellement important
qu'on organise la vie de la société
autour de ça
tant qu'on pense que le plus important
c'est d'avoir une machine à laver pour
pas cher chez darty puis oublié ce
problème
aussi bête que ça je suis pas en train
de vous accuser juste en train de dire
le choix tel qu'il se présente à nous
c'est celui-là qui il y en a pas d'autre
c'est une honte
alors ces fameuse émission qu'il faut
diviser par 3 on va maintenant se
pencher un peu plus dessus et regardez
où est ce que les méchants de vaches et
méchante bête à cornes se trouve vous
avez ici un camembert qui vous
représente le les émissions planétaires
de gaz à effet de serre nouveau il n'y a
pas les intitulés comme ça et pas de
spoiler
20% des émissions planétaires vielle des
centrales à charbon
alors il centrales à charbon c'est une
bouilloire c'est tout bête hein c'est
une machine à vapeur avec du charbon ont
fait de la chaleur avec la chaleur on
fait de la vapeur et avec la vapeur ont
fait tourner une turbine qui fait
tourner un alternateur comme dans votre
voiture mais il est beaucoup plus gros
et c'est ça une centrale électrique à
charbon
la moitié de ces centrales sont en chine
donc dès que vous achetez un truc made
in china vous acheter un truc made in
charbon
la quantité de charbon utilisé
indirectement par les français à travers
leurs importations chinoises a
considérablement augmenté sur les 20
dernières années donc mes chers
compatriotes vous et nous utilisons
beaucoup plus de charbon aujourd'hui
qu'il ya 20 ans alors qu'on pense que on
en utilise pas à cause de médine charbon
8% des émissions planétaires c'est des
centrales à gaz est beaucoup plus
marginalement les centrales à fuel donc
ce que sont en train de faire en ce
moment nos voisins belges qui consiste à
fermer du nucléaire pour construire des
centrales à gaz ça va à rebours de ce
qui fait baisser les émissions tout le
droit de le faire pour d'autres raisons
mais en tout cas au niveau des émissions
ça va les faire remonter c'est
absolument certain
4% des émissions planétaires c'est les
cimenteries
dans les cimenteries vous avez un
processus chimique qui consiste à casser
du calcaire en deux morceaux l'un des
deux morceaux sert à faire le ciment et
l'autre morceau c'est du co2 qui part
dans l'atmosphère
12% c'est les autres émissions directes
des industries d'adam vous avez aussi 4%
pour la syrie et 4% pour la chili donc
fabriquer des matériaux de base du
ciment du plastique des métaux et
notamment de l'acier c'est ça qui est
mais l'essentiel de l'industrie enfin
c'est ça l'essentiel des émissions
directes de l'industrie après
transformer l'acier ambulants 12 c'est
beaucoup moins émissifs ce qui veut dire
que tous les objets que nous achetons
l'important ce n'est pas de bien les
jeter c'est pas les acheter
si on veut faire des grosses économies
d'émissions l'important ce n'est pas de
bien jeter et de bien recycler c'est de
ne pas acheter
c'est à ce moment là qu'on évite les
émissions
5% c'est les chaudières de bâtiments osé
dire commence à 5% les bâtiments ça
crache beaucoup plus de co2 que ça on
n'arrête pas d'entendre en france le
bâtiment c est oui alors ok parce qu'en
france on n'a pas de centrale à charbon
très bonne idée on a peu de centrales à
gaz très bonne idée on a moins
d'aciéries et de cimenterie parce qu'on
a eu une industrie qui est beaucoup
moins forte que dans d'autres pays
notamment parce qu'on a fille conçue à
deauville et ça ça compte ça bouffe
énormément de ciment et d'acier et c'est
donc chez nous le chauffage c'est
beaucoup plus gros c'est pas pour cent
mais dans le monde par ailleurs dans le
monde tous les bâtiments sont pas
chauffées voilà donc dans le monde ces 5
% les transports ces 15% dans lesquels
vous allez trouver à peu près 6 % pour
les voitures 4% pour les camions c'est
mondial tous à 2% pour les bateaux et 2%
pour l'aviation preco vide
non cela c'est 2020 dont deux pour cent
pour la question sur
le
vous voyez que les transports tout
mouillé dans le monde c'est un gros
problème enfin c'est un gros sujet plus
exactement mais moins que les centrales
à charbon
donc dézinguer les centrales à charbon
c'est au moins aussi important que de
s'occuper des voitures
est alors après on va arriver à ce que
vous attendiez tous l'agriculture alors
l'agriculture dans le monde sait à peu
près 20% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est essentiellement des gaz qui
ne sont pas du co2 c'était dans le
premier graphique que je vous ai montré
là où vous avez vu il ya du méthane
notamment dans les émissions agricoles
et du protoxyde d'azoté
donc c'est essentiellement des gaz qui
ne sont pas du co2 et les gros postes
d'émission c'est les émissions de
protoxyde d'azoté une fois qu'on a mis
des engrais azotés dans les champs alors
les engrais azotés ça peut être des
engrais de synthèse où ça peut être du
purin ou ça peut être du lisier c'est
tout ça ça contient de la zone c'est
pour ça que ça pue du reste et puis vous
avez la fermentation entérique des
bovins qui si on pourrait pas faire de
tripes de caen 6 la mode de caen s'il
n'avait pas 4 istomin je connais même le
nom et les rizières donc ça c'est les
gros postes de décision alors en europe
l'agriculture c'est aussi à peu près 20%
des émissions mais dans le monde il faut
y rajouter un autre compartiment qu'en
europe on a plus parce qu'on a déjà
coupé tout ce qu'ils avaient à couper la
couverture forestière de l'europe a
fortement diminué au deuxième millénaire
pour arriver à son minimum en 1850 donc
non à déforester massivement là ça s'est
arrêté mais dans le monde c'est pas le
cas et donc il ya 10% des émissions
planétaires qui viennent de la
déforestation qui est un déterminant
amont de l'agriculture ce qui veut dire
que si je rajoute la déforestation et
les émissions directes de l'agriculture
cette dernière représente un tiers des
émissions planétaires de gaz à effet de
serre ça fait quand même un gros paquet
il a deux dans les deux déterminants
donc le premier vous allez pas me sauter
dessus le deuxième ris le premier
déterminant c'est la taille de la
population plus on est nombreux plus
être surfaces agricoles et le deuxième
déterminant c'est la part de viande dans
la ration alimentaire parce que plus on
mange d'animaux plus il faut de végétaux
pour nourrir les animaux
donc plus on a besoin de surfaces
et enfin vous avez 7 % qui sont des
poudres de perlimpinpin diverses donc là
dedans vous avez les fuites de circuits
réfrigérant les frigos les chaînes du
froid dans les industries
agroalimentaires
vous avez les émissions de la gestion
des déchets parce que les décharges cd
espèce de grosse estomac de vache c'est
ça fermente aussi
voilà vous avez un certain nombre de
petits de petits trucs
alors voilà je choisis ton camp camarade
et qu'est-ce qu'on divise par trois là
dedans
on a coutume de se focaliser sur le plus
gros déterminant de la sphère qui est
l'utilisation de l'énergie c'est à dire
les émissions de co2 mais vous voyez qui
a pas que ça dans les émissions
d'origine agricole alors je vais quand
même faire un petit crochet par
l'énergie maintenant avant de revenir
l'agriculture
puisque c'est quand même à l'origine
d'une bonne partie des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
l'énergie est un sujet quand on le
regarde quelle est sa vie médiatique
qui est très souvent pris par un prisme
qui n'est pas celui qui est le plus
pertinent pour bien s'occuper du
problème il ya un premier prisme qui je
suis sûr préoccupe certains d'entre vous
en ce moment dans cette salle qui est
que l'énergie fait penser à une facture
j'ai pas s'il ya des gens dans cette
salle qui sont chauffés au gaz mais
l'ancien chauffés au gaz ici oui mais la
facture augmente c'est les gens qui sont
chauffés à l'électricité
facture augmente donc se chauffer au
fioul peut-être à la facture augmente
donc c'est une facture alors c'est même
de temps en temps tellement une facture
qu'on en parle et on parle sur
l'électricité par le pour le gaz en
parle pour l'essence et sert alors en
fait malheureusement j'ai désolé de vous
le dire c'est pas le sujet comment ça
c'est pas le sujet doit pas payer sa
facture ainsi si je paye comme tout le
monde essaie pas de sujet vous allez
voir
prenons cette entreprise qui va amener
jusqu'à vous depuis mon domicile
s'appelle la 9e place 9e tir des trains
et accessoirement aussi de temps en
temps des bus et des camions au travers
de ses filiales mais là on va
s'intéresser au train pour tirer des
trains la snow ce feu a besoin de gens
qui travaillent à la sauce au feu
tout un tas de métiers très respectable
et quand vous regardez ce que ces gens
coûte à la semaine ce fun c'est à dire
les salaires des cheminots c'est à peu
près la moitié de ce que gagne la sncf
mais c'est pas les voyageurs qui font
pédaler les trains dont kiki pénale
pardon pour faire avancer les trains
donc la sncf a aussi besoin d'acheter de
l'électricité et du carburant pour faire
avancer ses trains de carburant du reste
j'ai découvert que le train qui venait à
rodez utilise du diesel senti match
phare big brain wolf
dans north bay il était très plein au
début donc là ça va j'ai la conscience
tranquille
et la sncf est le premier consommateur
d'électricité du pays c'est le plus gros
acheteur d'électricité de france
consomment 1,5 pour cent de la
production nationale et bien
l'électricité et le carburant que la
sncf achète lui coûte 3 % de ses revenus
alors maintenant imaginons que la sncf
baissé ses charges de 3%
option 1 elvire 6% de ses effectifs
grève monstrueuse plus de trains à rodez
pendant deux mois puis un jour la grève
s'arrête et il ya de nouveau des trains
à rodez d'accord il y en a peut-être 3%
- je ne sais pas mais enfin il ya
toujours des trains option 2 la sncf dit
j'arrête d'acheter j'arrête
l'électricité et le diesel il ya plus de
7 cm du tout
on est d'accord donc vous voyez bien que
la dépendance de cette activité à
l'énergie ne se reflète pas par la
facture
ces trois pour cent de ses coûts c'est
100% de son activité
bien ce que je vais essayer de vous
montrer maintenant c'est que c'est
exactement pareil en ce qui concerne
l'humanité
on s'en fout de savoir ce qu'on paye
d'énergie c'est 100 % de ce que nous
sommes c'est ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre
alors la deuxième manière dont l'énergie
est parfois prises dans le met dans le
débat médiatique c'est les économies
vous connaissez tous cette slogan la
meilleure énergie est celle
break aux appâts et ben vous n'avez rien
compris au film regardez on a un concept
de plus en plus donc vous êtes tous
nullement aussi des meilleure énergie
c'est celle qu'on consomme et on va voir
ensuite pourquoi ici vous avez la
quantité totale d'énergie utilisée par
l'humanité depuis un siècle et demi
alors vous voyez manifestement on en
consomme de plus en plus donc on n'a pas
bien écouté les slogans
et non seulement on en consomme de plus
en plus mais ce que vous voyez c'est que
chaque forme d'énergie est venu
s'empiler sur les précédentes sans
aucune substitution à large échelle
donc le charbon on n'a pas rempli ses
devoirs il est dû par dessus et on n'a
jamais consommé autant de charbon
aujourd'hui le pétrole est venu par
dessus de charbon il ya pas du tout
remplacer le gaz est venu par dessus le
pétrole et le charbon le et c est tout
en haut là vous avez les machins qui en
ce moment remplissent les colonnes des
journaux c'est à dire les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables donc là le petit
machin move là en haut c'est
l'agrégation du photovoltaïque de
l'éolien du biogaz du marais moteur du
rouleau moteur de chez pac ou encore des
hydroliennes enfin bon bref tout ça
c'est ce truc là
et alors la promesse aujourd'hui c'est
que ce truc mauvais va remplacer en
trente ans la totalité de tout ça
dans un monde dans lequel la quantité
d'énergie utilisée doubles
c'est ça la promesse politique
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle la croissance
verte alors ne rigolez pas c'est comme
ça que l'europe organise ses plans
c'est comme ça que l'aïe agence
internationale de l'énergie publie ses
scénarios
c'est comme ça que les économistes
résonne
donc je pense que là vous avez un peu
moins rigoler c'est exactement comme ça
que en ce moment le débat s'organise
donc maintenant je pourrais faire un
petit sondage à chaud qu'il croit
alors si vous vous y croyez pas ça veut
dire que moins d'énergies fossiles vous
comprenez que ça va être moins d'énergie
tout court
et on va voir que ça veut dire en fait
très mauvaise nouvelle pour vous et pour
moi moins de pouvoir d'achat taux
courants c'est ça que ça veut dire
l'essentiel de l'énergie c'est des
énergies fossiles aujourd'hui l'énergie
des énergies fossiles c'est à dire
charbon pétrole et gaz qu'on appelle
comme ça parce que c'est vraiment des
fossiles cd reste devient ancien hein le
charbon c'est une reste c'est un reste
de fougères qui a poussé à l'ère du
charbon le carbonifère 300 millions
d'années et le pétrole et le gaz c'est
des restes de plancton et d'algues qui
ont vécu n'importe quand entre il ya 5
millions d'années il ya 400 millions
d'années
donc c'est vraiment des fossiles
donc
facture ça se discute façon d'études
mais c'est pas le sujet principal
l'économie manifestement c'est parce
qu'on a fait alors l'autre truc je vous
dis c'est maintenant on va être tout
renouvelable j'ai très bonne nouvelle
pour vous tous renouvelables il ya aucun
problème pour être tous renouvelables
aucun problème c'est très facile d'être
tous renouvelables voilà par exemple un
exemple tout renouvelable
ça c'est tout renouvelable en fait tout
renouvelable c'est le monde dans lequel
elle a vécu l'humanité depuis ses
origines jusqu'à il ya deux siècles
donc je ne sais pas vous dire si les
renouvelables celles à venir mais il ya
une chose que je sais vous dire c'est
que c'est le passé de façon absolument
certaine c'est historiquement les
énergies dont nous sommes sortis sur les
deux derniers siècles alors à nouveau
peut-être qu'on était le dernier des
crétins ou peut-être qu'il ya une très
bonne raison à ce qu'on ait fait ça il
ya aussi de très gros inconvénient à ce
qu'on ait fait ça mais il y avait
peut-être de très bonnes raisons parce
que si vous regarder dans le détail on
avait une marine parfaitement
renouvelables c'est pas vraiment le cas
aujourd'hui
on avait des transports terrestres
parfaitement renouvelables le cheval y
mange de l'herbe renouvelables après
moment je le cheval renouvelables pour
ça qu'ils avaient des boucheries
chevalines partout à l'époque des
chevaux de trait il était quand même pas
question de laisser partir sa aux
asticots 1
et c'est pas vraiment ça qu'on a
aujourd'hui comme mode de transport on
avait une agriculture donc parfaitement
renouvelables et aujourd'hui on n'a pas
vraiment une agriculture parfaitement
renouvelables on avait des travaux
publics parfaitement renouvelables ça
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui on avait
une construction parfaitement
renouvelables de siècle pour faire notre
dame aujourd'hui vous faites des grands
cornichons à la défense en un siècle en
un an par dont on avait une industrie
renouvelables un déboule un aow avec qui
alimentait des soufflet de forge en cuir
enfin tout ça était parfaitement
renouvelables aujourd'hui pour remplir
toys'r'us on utilise ça et on avait même
des séchoirs de récolte parfaitement
renouvelables c'est en voilà et voilà
alors celui-là en l'occurrence il
fonctionne au biogaz j'ai pris une
mauvaise photo puisse pas grave il
fonctionnerait pas au biogaz ça serait
pareil et maintenant on a des séchoirs
luzerne parfaitement fossiles qui
fonctionnent au gaz donc pardon le
dernier petit point on avait même
une aviation parfaitement renouvela donc
ici vous reconnaissez la montgolfière
chauffer au bois renouvelables fait en
papier renouvelables etc et on a fait
des trucs qui n'était pas vraiment donc
en fait ça fait deux siècles qu'on passe
notre temps à des renouvelables is et
l'énergie qu'on utilise donc est ce
qu'on va pouvoir garder une civilisation
industrielle avec la machine n'avait pas
cherché darty avec 100 % d'énergie
renouvelable comme dit l'autre ça se
discute
je pense qu'avant d'accepter ce slogan
et de le prendre pour argent comptant
je vous invite à regarder bien les
petites lignes du contrat très très en
détail
en fait la bonne réponse et la réponse
des d'habitude et la réponse des la
voici
l'énergie c'est ça
l'énergie c'est ça alors vous allez dire
non ça c'est pas l'énergie c'est un
héros de film on le connaît encore ses
héros de films américains qui sont là
pour tout casser il enfile son d'armures
et paf il a sauvé le monde alors non en
fait c'est vraiment ça l'énergie parce
que l'énergie en fait c'est la
nourriture de cette armure que nous
portons tous à dire non ne porte pas une
armure monsieur y porte une écharpe
madame elle porte un masque de
restauration dans la sphère suez au
front je vois un pull en laine pas du
tout on passe ici en fait on porte tous
ce costume sur nous sauf qu'il n'a pas
cette tête là il a c'est peut-être là
mais il remplit exactement les mêmes
fonctions c'est à dire que grâce à cet
engin là eh bien mon bras gauche voit sa
puissance des x 10 mille
grâce à cet engin là la cuisse droite
voit sa puissance des x 5000 et c'est
donc en fait le costume d'iron man si la
totalité des machines qui fonctionne
grâce à l'énergie que nous leur donnons
à manger car l'énergie c'est pas vous
qui l'a consommée en fait quand vous
payez votre facture d'électricité
c'est pas pour vous brancher le la prise
dans les narines
et en tout cas si vous faites ça vous
n'allez pas vous mettre à éclairer la
pièce ou à laver le linge
donc l'énergie en fait c'est de la
nourriture pour machines c'est ça
l'énergie est donc utiliser de l'énergie
c'est donner des ordres à des machines
c'est ça que ça veut dire utiliser de
l'énergie s'est donné des ordres des
machines et les machines auquel on donne
des ordres font notre costume d'iron man
ce costume d'iron man il est vraiment
très très puissant alors je suis désolé
de pas prendre un parallèle aveyronnais
mais imaginons que vous alliez chez vos
cousins de savoie
qui ont aussi des races de vaches de
montagne et que vous alliez faire
l'ascension du mont blanc dans la
journée on partait de chamonix le matin
arrivée au sommet du mont blanc le soir
et bien si vous faites ça vos jambes or
on fournit une puissance moyenne dans la
journée d'à peu près une centaine de
watts
ça fait pas bézef ça fait quand même pas
beaucoup
maintenant vous allez prendre un mixeur
à soupe puisque c'est un vide sera
souple tout coin
et bien quand vous appuyez sur le bouton
sur l'interrupteur de votre mixeur à
soupe vous avez instantanément quatre
alpinistes bien entraînés ou quatre
cyclistes bien entraînés qui se mettent
à pédaler pour vous de ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire le mont blanc dans la
journée la bouffe
passer l'aspirateur dix cyclistes se
mettent à pédaler pour vous appeler
l'ascenseur 50 cyclistes se mettent à
pédaler pour vous monter dans un engin
de travaux publics alors là c'est pas
des cyclistes cd je vais pas des
bûcherons plutôt 10000 bûcheron se met à
faire travailler leurs bras pour vous
c'est à dire que quand l'ouvrier rentrer
dans la cabine de pilotage d'un engin de
travaux publics il démultiplie la
puissance de ses bras par dit bill
camp roberge pas pourquoi les chauffeurs
de camion s'appelle tous robert non
c'est parce que mon maraîchers
s'appelait robert il ya des marques et
robert sur son camion
monde dans son camion et bien il
démultiplie la puissance de ses jambes
par 4000
et quand l'ouvrier de dunkerque ou de
fos-sur-mer rentrer dans la cabine de
pilotage du laminoir il démultiplie la
puissance de ses bras par 10 millions
pour remplacer les deux laminoirs que
nous avons en france à dunkerque et à
fos sur mer
par des ouvriers qui martèle ray sur la
tôle toute la journée pour écraser la
tôle avec la même puissance il faudrait
que je mette au travail la totalité de
la population active du secteur privé en
france
la totalité du secteur privé devrait
marteler sur des tôles toute la journée
juste y compris agriculteurs juste pour
remplacer deux laminoirs que nous avons
en france donc j'ai pas vous voyez un
peu la puissance des machines et le
laminoir il vous sert tous et toutes
dans cette salle vous êtes assis sur des
chaises qui ont des armatures en acier
vous avez chez vous des objets de
cuisine des fourchettes des couteaux des
meubles des bâtiments tout ça ça
contient de l'acier donc de même n'y a
pas de vie sans énergie fossile
aujourd'hui enfin n'y a pas
d'organisation sociale sans énergie
fossile y a pas plus d'organisations
sociales sont en acier aujourd'hui la
rambarde qui vous empêchera de vous
casser la gueule la boîte en acier un
porte manteau tout acier par tous
d'accord
alors c'est aussi vrai dans
l'agriculture donc dans l'agriculture
donc je suis désolé de dire
l'agriculteur qui compte pour peanuts
face à ces machines voilà je suis désolé
de vous le dire j'espère que vous
accepterez quand même de payer mon hôtel
voilà b vous vous à côté de vos machines
n'existait pas pour un tracteur tracteur
c'est ça petit tracteur un céréalier de
la beauce
et bien alors c'est pas un tout petit
tracteur si vous allez prendre un
enjambeur viticole et en rollat et bien
c'est des centaines de paires de jambes
que le tracteur est capable de remplacer
ou des dizaines d'animaux à clé en gros
vous / 7 et ça vous donne le nombre de
chevaux que ça fait donc là vous voyez
60 kilowatts ses 90 chevaux donc c'est
comme s'il y avait 90 chevaux attelés
mais c'est pas le même prix c'est pas le
même prix
voilà la plus grosse moissonneuse
batteuse du monde j'ai été la chercher
alors je pense pas que vous l'ayez en
aveyron celle là sans vraiment n'est pas
vraiment nécessaire
mais celle là donc 500 kilowatts allait
elle fait quasiment 700 chevaux attelés
pas si vous voyez 700 chevaux j'ai même
pas si elle a cette chance chevaux de
trait dans le département même pas sûr
qu'il n'est pas sûr qu'ils existent
alors voilà d'autres petits copains et
auxiliaires de l'agriculture qui
s'appelle les usines d'engrais et de
phytosanitaires
les engrais de synthèse sont faits avec
la chimie de l'ammoniac et la chimie de
l'ammoniac demande de commencer à
produire un gaz qui est achement à la
mode en ce moment et qui s'appelle
de l'hydrogène absolument 40% de
l'hydrogène qui est aujourd'hui produit
dans le monde sert à faire de l'ammoniac
et l'ammoniac c'est le début de la
chimie des engrais c'est avec ça qu'on
fait l'urée et c'est que derrière on va
faire les engrais azotés les
ammonitrates ceux qui font boum dans le
port de beyrouth cantal et surveille pas
d'autres usines que vous voyez là c'est
un aval du pétrole c'est de la
pétrochimie c'est les phytosanitaires et
les trois piliers énergétique de
l'agriculteur moderne s'appelle la
mécanisation les engrais azotés et les
phytosanitaires et un peu marginalement
aussi d'autres engrais qui arrive par
exemple dans ce genre de bateau qui sont
les phosphates voilà et la potasse
pour faire le npk donc aujourd'hui
l'agriculture moderne bénéficie de ce
costume d'iron man exactement comme les
autres activités et si la raison pour
laquelle la population active a pu
descendre jusqu'à 1,5 pour cent
des actifs français en produisant bien
plus que à l'époque où ça occupe et 60%
des français parce qu'on habille les
machines au boulot
prenons donc la délicieuse assiette du
repas ou du petit déjeuner elle est
environné de machines donc elle commence
par bénéficier de la mécanisation dans
les champs mais elle bénéficie également
de l'extraction pétrolière qui permet
derrière de faire fonctionner les usines
de phytosanitaires et l'extraction
gazière qui permet de produire
l'hydrogène parce que l'hydrogène effet
en craquant du méthane donc ça c'est du
gaz naturel
elle bénéficie des mines de phosphates
dont vous avez ici un exemple encore des
machines donc tout ça ça entoure votre
assiette du petit déjeuner bénéficient
de trains pour transporter les céréales
ensuite bénéficient des usines de
transformation
parce que pour faire votre paquet d'une
marque que je ne nommerai pas il a fallu
que ça passe dans des usines de reste
même pour faire du fromage certaine
manière des usines ça bénéficie de la
fabrication des emballages une bonne
partie des emballages servent à emballer
les aliments et puis des eu tant de fois
des usines pour les fabriquer et puis
des camions et puis des machines de
froid et puis les machines de chaud donc
voilà votre assiette du petit déjeuner
elle baigne dans les machines d'accord
sans machine aujourd'hui vous avez pas
de petit déjeuner ni de déjeuner ni
dîner
vous vivez peut-être vous dans une
région dans laquelle si demain matin il
y avait plus de camions vous
continueriez à avoir à manger
moi je vis dans une région dans laquelle
on meurt de faim s'il ya plus de camions
l'ile-de-france produit 6 % de
l'alimentation des franciliens
donc pas de camion pas bouffer
la dépendance à laval de l'agriculture
et j'y reviendrai à la fin de cette
intervention la dépendance à laval de
l'agriculture et massive à la dépendance
pardon de l'agriculture au pétrole à
laval est absolument massive
alors cette énergie elle a fait fondre
les effectifs agricole comme neige au
soleil et c'est ça qui l'a fait fondre
vous avez ici les effectifs la
population active en france jusqu'en
1996 ça s'arrête mais la décrue continue
et derrière ça c'était l'époque bénie où
il y avait un million de personnes dans
l'agriculture
maintenant je crois qu'on doit est à 6
ans 500000 même pas
pardon 500 milles voilà
déjà en plus perdu la moitié par rapport
à la petite partie maigrichonne là de la
fin du xxème siècle comment ça se lit ce
graphique vous voyez que en 1800 donc il
ya deux siècles les deux tiers de la
population active sont agricoles ça veut
dire qu'à l'époque comme manger c'est le
premier besoins des animaux que nous
sommes un agriculteur est suffisamment
productif pour se nourrir lui plus une
dolly personne qui fait autre chose
c'est ça que ça veut dire
donc avec ce qu'ils cultivent il arrive
à manger lui
plus une demi personne ouvrière ou
dans les services les quelques rentiers
voyez que la population active augmente
jusqu'en 1850 alors à cette époque là
les agriculteurs sont pas beaucoup plus
productif en 50 ans par compte la france
n'a pas fini de des fichiers n'a pas
fini de déforester les surfaces
cultivées augmente et donc on peut avoir
plus de monde dans les champs et plus de
monde à nourrir globalement la
population augmente globalement
1850 minimum forestier à partir de ce
moment là les surfaces à cultiver
n'augmente plus par contre l'industrie
va commencer à équiper les agriculteurs
avec des machines de plus en plus
performantes d'écoliers très enfin donc
là les machines sont pas dans les champs
mais par contre les machines sont dans
l'industrie 1 les forges etc et on va
leur donner des socs de charrue de plus
en plus performant des attelages de plus
en plus performant des colliers de
traits de plus en plus performants et
c'est dès le début des morceaux de ce
batteuse c'est 1900 c'est donc on va ils
vont avoir des auxiliaires et donc ils
vont devenir de plus en plus productifs
et puis après la guerre arras et ironman
déboule dans les champs tracteur
phytosanitaires engrais le rendement
céréalier dans la beauce a été multiplié
par cinq en 30 ans
donc ça c'est de l'énergie perfusion
d'énergie
que font les autres et bien les autres
ils ont de l'énergie aussi donc on va
pouvoir avoir un parc de machines
croissant qui va faire autre chose que
de s'occuper de la chaîne a de la chaîne
agroalimentaire en particulier on a des
machines qui commence à exister pour
extraire des matériaux dans les mines et
transformer ces matériaux derrière et à
ce moment on a besoin de plus en plus de
gens pour faire fonctionner ces machines
donc un emploi dans l'industrie
s'est depuis l'origine un emploi de
serviteurs de machines une machine un
emploi
deux machines deux emplois trois
machines trois emplois de plus en plus
d'énergie de plus en plus de machines de
plus en plus d'emplois très simple
de plus en plus de machines de plus en
plus d'objets produits de plus en plus
d'emplois de services parce qu'il faut
les vendre il faut les assurés il faut
les entretenir il faut former les gens
pour fabriquer les machines qui vont
fabriquer les objets etc tout ça c'est
des emplois de service
les emplois de service sont la
conséquence de l'augmentation des flux
industriels permis par l'énergie les
emplois de service ne se détache pas des
flux industriels sous jacent
après les chocs pétroliers
la quantité d'énergie par personne en
occident arrête d'augmenter en fête les
chocs pétroliers ça a marqué l'arrêt de
la hausse de la quantité d'énergie par
personne en occident à ce moment là on
augmente la taille des machines si on
augmente la taille des machines on
diminue le nombre de machines
et donc on va pouvoir exactement si on
les augmente vite on va diminuer la
taille le nombre d'emplois industriels
alors même que la production
industrielle continue d'augmenter donc
on va produire plus avec beaucoup moins
de machines et donc avec beaucoup moins
d'emplois
par contre comme la production
industrielle augmente
nombre d'emplois de services augmentent
il ya plus en plus de jouer à vendre de
plus en plus d'employés de la
distribution de plus en plus d'employés
dans la banque pour faire des crédits
pour acheter les jouets etc plus en plus
de gens partout dans les services
de plus en plus de gens pour former
parce que le monde est plus en plus
compliqué et c'est donc le nombre le
nombre de genres dans les services
augmente alors même que le nombre
d'employés dans l'industrie baisse et
enfin après les chocs pétroliers
un emploi est devenu tellement productif
parce qu'on a tellement de machines par
personne
que le ralentissement sur l'énergie fait
qu'on ne peut plus donner un emploi par
personne et donc à partir des chocs
pétroliers pour maintenir l'activité il
aurait fallu commencer à ralentir la
hausse de la productivité voir l'inversé
aujourd'hui on est rentré dans un monde
où si on veut donner un job à tout le
monde sans s'endetter il faut diminuer
la productivité du travail est pas
l'augmenter dit perturbant pas ce que ça
veut dire aussi diminué revenus
donc c'est pas 35 heures payées 46 35
heures payées 35 ça que ça voulait dire
au moment où les socialistes ont fait
les 35 heures s'il avait voulu vraiment
répondre au problème 1 c'était ça qu'il
fallait qu'il fasse c'était pas 35
heures payées 47 et 35 heures payées 35
c'était ça le vrai partage d'un travail
qui ne pouvaient plus augmenté à ce
moment là peau des régions énergétique
pop pas du tout pour des raisons autres
pour des raisons énergétiques
alors ce que je vous ai expliqué là pour
la france on le constate partout dans le
monde ici vous avez par exemple un
graphique où j'ai mis pour chaque chaque
point bleu est un pays dans le monde et
pour le point et pour le pays en
question j'ai mis à la fois la part de
la population active qui travaillent
dans l'agriculture là et la quantité
d'énergie par personne dans le pays ça
c'est l'axé horizontal est ce que vous
voyez c'est que si on prend une photo du
monde aujourd'hui plus un pays à
d'énergie par personne - il a des gens
dans l'agriculture
donc dès que l'approvisionnement
énergétique augmente dans un pays la
quantité d'agriculteurs baisse
et les gens vont se mettre dans les
villes où ils font de l'industrie puis
des services donc là je suis en train de
vous dire qu'une civilisation très
urbaine est une civilisation très
énergivores et dans un monde à l'énergie
rare ça pourra pas rester comme ça on va
devoir faire dégonfler les villes au
comment on fait
sans y réfléchir on fait pas ça c'est
sûr
et si on fait pas qu'est ce qui se passe
eh bien les villes vont progressivement
connaître des problèmes économiques
croissants
à commencer par les banlieues ça
s'explique de manière énergétique
portant ce soir
voilà comment la france et transformé
sous le coût de l'approvisionnement
énergétique en quelques décennies les
campagnes se sont vidées les villes ont
grossi et comme par ailleurs tout le
monde avait une voiture les villes se
sont grossit grossit en ses talents
partout pareil quel que soit le pouvoir
politique en place c'est pas ça s'est
passé exactement de la même manière en
grande bretagne en france en allemagne
ici et là les endroits où les villes se
sont pas étalées c'est parce que la
géographie le permettait pas donc si
vous allez voir les villes suisses à
fond de vallée s'étaler sur les coteaux
c'est quand même compliqué donc les
villes se sont peu étalé
bt que vous étiez dans des pays de
plaine ce qui est le cas pour
l'essentiel de la france
on a produit plus d'aliments et on les a
produits pour moins cher ici vous avez
alors ça je pense que ça va vous
intéresser
l'évolution du budget alimentaire alors
j'ai pris les américains parce qu'en
france on est infoutue de trouver des
séries longues en deux clics de ceux de
souris
mais c'est exactement la même chose en
france le budget alimentaire des
américains sur quasiment un siècle ce
que vous voyez c'est qu'il ya un siècle
les anime les américains dépensent un
quart de ce qu'ils gagnent pour manger
et là dedans l'essentiel c'est ce qu'on
appelle au domicile donc en fait c'est
des achats pour faire la cuisine vous
même
je suis désolé des propos sexistes qui
vont suivre mais c'est quoi la façon de
procéder du ménage américain il ya un
siècle et bien c'est madame stif qui va
au marché ou voir le paysan du coin pour
acheter des produits bruts qu'elle
rentre cuisiner chez elle pour monsieur
smith qui est auchan ou à jean
donc l'essentiel des achats alimentaires
à l'époque payent effectivement de la
nourriture en direct
qu'est ce que c'est que les achats
alimentaires aujourd'hui c'est le ticket
de caisse du magasin
mais quand vous allez chez carrouf pour
acheter de la nourriture qu'est ce qui
revient aux gens qui sont au premier
rang là
vous allez payer le magasinier de chez
carrouf la caissière de chez carrouf
vous allez payer des transports vous
allez payer des emballages allait payer
la campagne de pub de carreaux vous
allez payer les actionnaires de karouf
et leurs experts comptables vous allez
payer en gros tout sauf de la bouffe
j'ai fait de calculs sur une boîte de
thon en boîte d'oeufs de poule en
batterie que j'achète jamais mais c'est
quand même comme ça que je vais faire un
calcul départ producteurs en bretagne
l'offre aussi centimes donc une boîte de
6 36 centimes que vous allez payer 1
euro 50 au magasin
d'accord donc vous allez payer au
magasin en gros
entre un quart et un cinquième de votre
ticket de caisse c'est effectivement
l'achat de la nourriture l'eau reste
payent plein d'autres trucs si vous
achetez un paquet de pâtes c'est
exactement pareil quand vous regardez le
blé et l'eau qui servent à faire les
pattes c'est une c'est juste un tout
petit morceau du paquet de pâtes que
vous achetez donc en fait à l'époque on
achetait des produits bruts et on
faisait la cuisine soi-même en fait ce
qu'on appelle faire la cuisine
aujourd'hui c'est déjà acheté des
produits de l'industrie agroalimentaire
des trucs en concert destruction gelé
des trucs sécher des trucs machins
emballé c'est donc les produits bruts
ils valent un quart de votre ticket de
caisse en gros et quand vous êtes hors
domicile c'est encore pire puisque mais
loeb est ce que je paye 5 euros dans un
bistrot parisien qui contient 3 e
contient 18 centimes 2
est tout sauf de la bouffe
donc si je regarde le vrai facteur
diviseur sur l'alimentation elle même
c'est à dire que si on revenait
aujourd'hui au système d'il ya un siècle
où on se contentait tous d'acheter des
fruits et légumes et de la viande aux
producteurs du coin qu'on cuisine chez
nous ce qui est pas possible dans le
système urbain actuel non mais c'est
juste pour et bien en fait on se
rendrait compte que le prix des aliments
a été divisé par 10 à 20
donc la boue fallait pas cher il vaut
rien en ce moment rien du tout rien
c'est transitoire ça va remonter je peux
vous le dire et ça va pas remonter parce
que les politiques sont des abrutis ça
va remonter à cause de la physique
des coûts de la physique
et dans le même temps on consomme 5 fois
plus de viande
donc le prix réel de la viande c'est à
dire le prix d'un kilo de boeuf exprimé
en minutes de temps de travail
lui il a plutôt été divisée par 50 à 100
c'est ça l'ordre de grandeur
je vais revenir maintenant à un effet
macroscopique donc à mon costume d'iron
man vous avez compris que c'est lui qui
a totalement transformé le monde est en
fait si j'essaye de comprendre combien
il a transformé le monde avec les petits
multiples que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure la tractopelle dix mille bras et
c'est un petit calcul de
d'ordre de grandeur vous montre que ces
machines et leur nourriture spéciale qui
s'appelle d'énergie
démultiplie aujourd'hui la force
musculaire de l'humanité par un facteur
de sens
si nous n'avions pas d'énergie sur terre
donc pas de pétrole pas de gaz pas de
charbon et marginalement pas d'eau pas
d'uranium et c est bien la force
productive de l'humanité serait divisé
par un facteur 2 sans
autre manière de dire ça c'est que le
pib serait divisé par un facteur 2 ans
dans le monde le pib par personne sera
divisé par un facteur 50 à 100 votre
pouvoir d'achat or il serait divisé par
un facteur 50 à 100 donc ce qui a fait
votre pouvoir d'achat et le mien ça
s'appelle le pétrole le gaz le charbon
c'est ça qui a fait votre pouvoir de
règne
et ça se retrouve sur cette courbe qui
vous donne le pib mondial sur l'axé
vertical en fonction de la quantité
d'énergie c'est-à-dire le parc de
machines que nous avons un service dans
le monde voyez tout droit
plus il ya d'énergie utilisée dans le
monde plus on utilise deux machines plus
on produit et plus le pib est important
et comme l'essentiel de l'énergie et
fossiles bon on a la même chose sur le
pib le co2
donc là vous comprenez pourquoi la coop
26 recycle la coop 25 qui recyclent à
coop 24 qui etc ça veut dire que baisser
pour de vrai les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre cbc pour de vrai le pib
ah
voilà c'est ça le vrai sujet
et je vous dis ça parce que je suis un
grand partisan de la décroissance 60
vous allez voir qu'on y est déjà dans la
décroissance en europe donc le problème
est réglé mais
enfin il est en train de se régler mais
c'est exactement ça que ça veut dire
donc alors c'est ce que dans termes plus
policés on appelle la sobriété mais
c'est exactement ça donc aujourd'hui on
est à la croisée des chemins et la
question qu'on doit se poser c'est
est-ce que temps que la fête dure on y
va et tant pis pour la gueule de bois
ou bien est ce qu'on se dit non non on
veut durer pas que la fête mais on veut
que nous ça dure et à ce moment il va
falloir commencer à discuter de là où on
se met gentiment régime
mais c'est ça l'équation dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui vous comprenez
que c'est très difficile au monde
politique d'abord c'est très difficile
au monde politique d'écouté une heure et
demie comme vous êtes en train de le
faire sagement bientôt je vais m'arrêter
et ensuite c'est très difficile au monde
politique d'arriver à gérer ce problème
en tenant compte de nos contradictions
qui je suis sûr pour une partie des gens
dans cette salle n'était pas consciente
au moment où vous êtes rentré
mais on est en plein dans des
contradictions les notre propre
donc l'âge d'or que nous sommes en train
de vivre il a une origine les
combustibles fossiles qui sont aussi
gratuite le vent le vent est gratuit
mais la formation du pétrole est
gratuite en personne à payer quoi que ce
soit dans cette salle pour que le
pétrole se forment donc toutes les
ressources naturelles sont gratuites
quelle qu'elle soit menad suivra gratuit
aussi donc le les combustibles fossiles
ça brûle ça que c'est les combustibles
ça permet de faire tourner des machines
qui permettent de transformer tout le
reste qui nous ont donné tous les objets
que nous connaissons qui nous en donne
est toute la structure sociale que nous
connaissons comme les machines cause
pour nous on a plein de temps libre donc
on peut faire des conférences et écouter
des conférences mais c'est pas vraiment
du travail d'accord c'est traire des
vaches écouter des conférences
vous faire des conférences donc on a
plein de temps libre donc on a des
vacances on a des noms commencent à
travailler tard on arrête de travailler
avant d'être mort
enfin voilà cry pas le week-end tout ça
c'est les machines qu'ils ont permis
tout ça c'est les machines le medef et
la cgt ne peuvent pas satisfaire leurs
revendications sans machine
effet né sera pas plus
pas de machine pas de revendications
et
au milieu de tout ça on a donc un truc
qu'on mesure qui s'appelle le pib on dit
tant que ça ça augmente c'est que tout
va bien
alors il ya au moins il ya plein de
limites planétaires à cette affaire
parce que la planète est fini il y en a
au moins deux donc une dont je vous ai
parlé en long en large et en travers
donc j'y reviendrai pas et une deuxième
qui est l'énergie puisque l'énergie
fossile il faut des dizaines ou des
centaines de millions d'années pour
qu'elles se forment donc elle n'est pas
vraiment renouvelables enfin les
renouvelables si vous avez le temps
d'atteindre 50 millions d'années mais
s'ils n'ont pas vraiment
les énergies fossiles dont le pétrole
gaz charbon
la plus importante d'entre elles
aujourd'hui dans l'approvisionnement
mondial c'est le pétrole
petite question j'ai offert un petit
quiz à votre avis ici qui pensent que du
pétrole pourvu qu'on en veuille il y en
a encore pour très longtemps
qui pense que même si on veut pas on va
dès à présent en avoir de moins en moins
bon elle a beaucoup qui pense plus
trop tard
j'avais essayé d'expliquer à ma fille
est née quand elle avait trois ans que
c'était que la mort j'avais dit quand on
est bon on pense plus je l'avais
retrouvé dans un frigo devant un poulet
en l'occurrence c'est une loi puisque
c'est noël et elle ouvre le frêle voit
le bestiau qu'elle se dit elle-même
j'étais dans la pièce à côté puis
j'entends dire elle même ce poulet bord
ils ne pensent plus
vous faites les poulets
et bien scellé deuxième qui ont raison
vous avez ici un document qui a été
édité par l' agence internationale de
l'énergie en 2018 et qui dit en ce qui
concerne le pétrole si je ne regarde pas
ce qu'on appelle le pétrole de schiste
aux états unis et les sables bitumineux
au canada la production mondiale de
pétrole est passé par un maximum
historique en 2008 et a commencé à
décliner depuis alors ce qui fait que
l'ensemble du pétrole n'a pas décliné et
je vais vous montrer juste après c'est
le pétrole de schiste et les sables
bitumineux mais sur le pétrole ordinaire
sarr a commencé à baisser depuis 2008
alors à cela s'est ajouté le pétrole de
schiste et le pétrole des sables
bitumineux et l'ensemble pourrait
continuer à croître dans le meilleur des
cas o'shea project nous on pense que ça
sera pas ça d'ici à 2030 mais ce que
vous disent graphique c'est un truc un
tout petit peu subtile et pour faire
sortir du pétrole faut utiliser de
l'énergie
puisque faut pomper et plus les
gisements se vide plus faut pomper être
vigueur pour faire sortir ce qui reste
donc ce qui va vraiment content et c'est
pas le pétrole brut qui sort c'est le
net une fois que vous avez déduit ce qui
vous était utile pour pomper
et là vous avez cette information sur le
graphique si vous enlevez l'énergie de
pompage on va dire l'énergie
d'extraction du pétrole c'est à dire
cette partie moutarde et bien au mieux
ce qui pourrait rester pour alimenter
nos machines c'est ce que vous avez ici
et là dedans vous n'avez même pas les
pertes au raffinage donc vous voyez que
il n'est pas exclu que si on regarde en
est eh bien le pic soit effectivement
passer au mieux on pourrait après le
qu'ovide remonter à quelque chose qui
est pas loin du pic pendant encore cinq
à dix ans ce qui serait déjà trop pour
le climat
mais là je vous parle de la géologie et
puis derrière ça pèse de toute façon
o'shea project on a demandé à deux
anciens dirigeants de total qui était du
côté de l'exploration production
donc ils cherchent le pétrole et qu'ils
font sortir et qui était très haut placé
dans la hiérarchie puisque l'un des deux
rôles numéro 2 et l'autre très loin du
numéro 3 on leur a donné une base de
données qu'on a eu pour un prix d'ami de
l'ensemble des gisements de pétrole dans
le monde truc qui normalement vous
quelques millions de dollars et les
pétroliers achète pour voir ce que font
leurs petits copains
que 12 dames on paye pour ce prix là où
chez project donc on a demandé à ses
anciens dirigeants de total de regarder
cette base de données est de nous faire
de nous donner leur pronostic sur la
quantité de pétrole qui pourrait sortir
des 16 premiers fournisseurs de l'europe
qui se trouve aussi être les 16 premiers
producteurs mondiaux sauf le canada et
le brésil si vous rajoutez le canada le
brésil vous avez tous les pays
producteurs importants dans la liste eh
bien vous voyez que leur pronostic c'est
que la production y compris le shale oil
qui est tout en haut là la production ne
reviendra pas à son niveau au preco vide
et dans cinq à dix ans elle se met à
piquer très sévèrement du nez alors ça
c'est la production des pays qui
exportent vers l'europe maillaud une
population domestique
ils ont leur propre aux automobilistes
ils ont leur propre gilet jaune ces gens
là
qui disent d'un pétrole il va rester
chez nous ce qui veut dire que la
quantité qui pourrait arriver en europe
en provenance de ses exportateurs elle
va pas être divisée par deux elle va
plutôt attiser par quatre si ce n'est
par cinq ou six
donc sur le pétrole la décrue elle a
commencé qu'on le veuille ou pas et donc
de toute façon qu'on le veuille ou pas
il va falloir organiser la sortie du
pétrole très rapidement de toute façon
qu'on le veuille ou pas donc il va
falloir de toute façon qu'on le veuille
ou pas pour ceux d'entre nous qui sont
chauffées au fioul plus chauffées au
fioul et pour ceux d'entre nous qui
utilise une voiture à pétrole faire
autre chose qu'une voiture à pétrole
de toute façon ça va être une mesure de
sauvegarde même si on se contrefout du
climat
même si on se contrefout du climat
voilà et je vais m'arrêter là j'avais
encore trois trucs sur l'agriculture
mais ça ferait un peu long
donc je m'arrête
et donc maintenant comme bon train et
demain matin bin temps vous êtes
réveillé allons-y pour les questions
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup je sais pas si tout le
monde est comme moi et c'est vrai que
peu
de votre sous le choc un peu voire
beaucoup d'infos messti c'était vraiment
passionnant
je vous invite à poser des questions si
vous en avez alors on va j'imagine cana
mais on va essayer de faire au mieux
donc voilà
oui non moi je vais préparer une
question mais on va d'abord faire celle
de la salle on y reviendra free en a une
en eau à laval à aller je viens
hop
alors merci pour la présentation pour
commencer pour ma question porte sur les
émissions de méthane liés au cheptel
bovin
alors j'ai pris j'ai essayé de prendre
quelques chiffres avant de venir
j'espère qu'ils sont bons à peu près en
france j'ai vu qu'on avait quelque chose
comme 18 millions de têtes bovines qui
émettait à peu près 2006 mégatonnes de
méthane par an et du coût pour nourrir
pardon j'ai été interrompu pour des
raisons de micro jeux d'accord du coup
je disais que le jusque de ce que
j'avais trouvé le cheptel bovin français
et mettait un peu près par an 1,6
mégatonnes de méthane quelque chose
donne ses ordres de grandeur la et du
coup pour pour nourrir tout ce bétail là
j'ai trouvé aussi qu'on faisait à peu
près 1 5 million d'hectares de maïs
fourrage qui on nous dit qu'il peut
capter du co2 de l'atmosphère jusqu'à 20
tonnes par par hectare et par an fin par
cycle de culture
donc si on fait le en première approche
le calcul on va dire on trouve que le
cheptel bovin il aimait 1,6 mégatonnes
de méthane par an mais en même temps ils
mangent des végétaux qui ont capté 30
mégatonnes de co2 par an donc bon je
j'imagine que le raisonnement est pas le
bon sinon les les vaches ne serait pas
l'ennemi public numéro 1 des émissions
de méthane donc voila j'aimerais avoir
un petit peu des explications par
rapport à ce phénomène là d'accord alors
la première chose que la première partie
de la réponse est que le méthane est un
gaz à effet de serre plus puissant que
le co2 c'est à dire qu'il a une capacité
à absorber les infrarouges terrestre qui
est plus élevée que celle du co2
par contre il a une durée de vie qui est
plus courte que celle du co2 parce que
c'est le seul gaz à effet de serre de ce
qu'on aimait qui a un processus
d'épuration dans l'atmosphère donc alors
il est pas très rapide ce processus mais
il existe quand même
au total on considère que émettre 1 kg
de méthane c'est à peu près comme
maîtres 28 kg de co2
ensuite quand on cultive des végétaux
pour donner à manger aux animaux les
animaux il respire et cette respiration
restitue sous forme de co2
l'essentiel tout le carbone en gros tout
le carbone qui rend rillaer sortir donc
il va le carbone qui rentre dans la bête
il va devenir une bonne partie va
devenir le co2 qu'elle exhale sa
respiration petite partie le co2
qu'elles puissent et qu'elle chi
pardonnez moi et enfin une petite partie
contribuer à son accroissement de masse
qu'ensuite nous allons manger et ça va
ressortir exactement de la même manière
chez nous donc je vous fait grâce
par la respiration et par le reste voilà
donc le l'ensemble du carbone qui aurait
été capté par la photosynthèse
ressort sous forme de co2 sauf une
petite partie qui ressort sous forme de
méthane
mais comme le méthane est un gaz à effet
de serre beaucoup plus puissant que le
co2 au total l'équation est défavorable
pour le cheptel bovin d'accord même si
on considère que les effluents d'élevage
dans l'hérault mais entre guillemets à
la télé alors heureux on les repose sur
nos voitures est ce qu'on considère que
ça le co2 qui est dedans retourne au sol
où il y en a quand même une petite
partie qui s'est encore un temps que
vous êtes avec une pratique agricole qui
est constante le contenu en carbone de
votre sol et constant si si vous voulez
enrichir et en fait c'est une d une
démarche de manoeuvre qu'il faut
développer dans l'agriculture le sol en
carbone les marges de manoeuvre
s'appelle y met des racines et arrêté
d'oxydé de carbone du sol alors y mettre
des racines c'est l'agroforesterie dans
les régions de bocage en général c'est
pas trop compliqué de convaincre les
gens qu'il faut mettre des ça devient
plus compliquée dans les régions de
culture un don qu'elle est maître des
airs dans la beauce c'est plus compliqué
mais c'est là où on devrait en mettre en
priorité et ensuite la deuxième chose
qu'il faut faire c'est la bourrée de
moins possible parce que plus vous la
pourrez plus vous exposez à l'oxygène de
l'air les molécules organiques du sol et
dont voulait minéralisées enfin vous
voilà voulez vous vous oxydé vous oxydé
le
le carbone de carbone du sol l'humus
en plus vous déranger les vers de terre
et donc ça ça contribue à ce que les
sols et met du carbone donc les
pratiques d'agriculture sans labour pour
ça qu'on présentait tout à l'heure sur
glyphosate
qui de mon point de vue j'ose le dire
des problèmes en pas le produit
phytosanitaire à interdire les pratiques
sans labour et les haies
sont une très bonne manière de remettre
du carbone dans les sols agricoles
je ne crois pas que qui que ce soit et
fait le calcul mais il serait
intéressant à faire de voir ce que ça
donne si vous passez des bovins de maïs
à pâturages mais je crois pas que le
problème dès lors la question se pose
tellement parce que je crois pas qu'il
reste de l'espace donc ça veut dire
qu'il faudrait transformer la culture de
maïs en pâturage et à ce moment effecté
donc vous auriez moins de bovins mais
par contre effectivement transitoirement
il faudrait faire le calcul de ce que ça
veut dire parce que si vous transformez
la culture en pâturage et que vous ne
pourrez pas votre nature âge vous allez
remettre du carbone dans le sol c'est
très clair
et dont il ya qu'il ya quelque chose à
regarder mais j'ai pas fai calcul
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
pendant que la deuxième question ah oui
je peux vous montrer un truc que j'avais
l'intention de vous montrer puis
finalement je voulais pas montrer c'est
la part de chaque composant dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'élevage donc là vous voyez tout à fait
enfin les deux ronds de gauche les deux
ados de gauche scellé peu vain et vous
voyez que le premier déterminant aux
émissions de l'élevage dans le cas des
bovins c'est la fermentation entérique
donc c'est là c'est le méthane qui vient
de la panse de la caillette du poney etc
ensuite vous avez les déjections donc ça
c'est la gestion des effluents week
l'alimentation l'agriculture ah bon
c'est pas un sujet majeur et puis en ce
qui concerne les laitiers vous avez
quand même un peu de fertilisation des
pâturages que vous voyez donc dans les
intrants quand vous êtes sur les porcins
les volailles c'est essentiellement
l'alimentation qui est à l'origine des
émissions c'est d'ailleurs ces deux
cultures hamon qui sont essentiellement
c'est les émissions des cultures hamon
qui sont essentiellement à l'origine des
émissions donc là là la structure est
pas du tout la même
moi j'ai une question vous parlez
d'agroforesterie est ce que si tous les
agriculteurs français se mettent à
l'agroforesterie de même on
la part de carbone va réduire de
quelques pourcentages
est-ce que ça a été calculée ou pas du
tout ce qui a aujourd'hui en france il
ya un truc s'appelle la stratégie
nationale bas carbone et dans le cadre
de cette stratégie nationale bas carbone
je vous avoue alors il ya des marges de
manoeuvre qui sont mentionnés sont les
suivantes
il ya effectivement l'augmentation de
carbone dans les sols agricoles
dans l'agroforesterie il peut y avoir
également un composant qui est pas
majeur mais qui est pas inintéressant
qui est le
le bois de taille
pour remplacer le fioul de chauffage
c'est pas énorme compte tenu des gens
que cela concerne enfin cette chose
appelée et puis
vous avez évidemment la séquestration de
carbone dans le sol parce que commencer
à mettre des arbres s'excuser de thaler
il ya les racines et les racines c'est
du carbone dans le sol
[Musique]
je ne fixe et les ordres de grandeur
aujourd'hui les émissions directes de la
france de gaz à effet de serre ses deux
plus déchirante a baissé de l'ordre de
400 millions de tonnes équivalent co2
l'empreinte carbone de la france
donc y compris les émissions qu'on
importe parce qu'on importe nos
téléviseurs que vous importez du soja
etc
à ce moment c'est plus proche de 650
millions de tonnes
et aujourd'hui le puits forestier il est
de quelques dizaines de millions de
tonnes donc si on augmente le puits
notamment avec des mesures
d'agroforesterie lob de grandeur qui a
dans la stratégie nationale bas carbone
c'est aussi quelques dizaines de
millions de tonnes dont quick à
l'échelle du pays c'est pas ça qui sert
à régler le problème mais c'est pas
complètement marginal et c'est toujours
bon à prendre
un
jour au monde n'ont pas augmenté dans
l'agro fort historique à 1 la foresterie
donc il ya aussi un point importante qui
est aussi un point du monde rural qui
est la forêt
aujourd'hui la forêt est un de nos
drames nationaux on a le deuxième massif
forestier d'europe et les meubles
c'est l'un des principaux postes de
déficit de la balance commerciale
on exporte des grimm pour importer du
parquet et des meubles
on a un vrai sujet avec le avec la forêt
aussi et dans la stratégie nationale bas
carbone un autre point important de
puits de carbone c'est d'augmenter les
objets en bois donc lieu sur les rangs
pour metal là vous la faites en bois
et du coup tant que la rampe et les sur
pied et qu'on l'a craint pas eh ben ça
fait un stock de carbone qui est plus
dans l'atmosphère
moi c'est notre question sur l'élevage
je veux que là il ya une part importante
de ces gestion des effluents
et logiquement dans un élevage extensif
où les vaches pâturent le fumier reste
sur les prairies il y en a une partie
qui parent protoxyde d azote qui en gaz
encore encore plus réchauffant que le
co2 par rapport à un élevage en bâtiment
on peut le stopper et capturer le
méthane et c est ce qu on a des chiffres
sur la contribution enfin les émissions
carbone en fonction du type d'élevage
plus ou moins non c'est une des
difficultés alors j'en parlais justement
avant le début de la conférence quand un
agriculteur veut faire son bilan carbone
à lui une des difficultés c'est que dans
le vivant les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre sont beaucoup plus fluctuantes
et variables que dans li na li vé quand
vous avez une voiture vous savez
exactement combien il va émettre en
fonction de la quantité d'essence
qu'elle consomme et vous savez que entre
l'horrible et suivez que je m efforce et
la toute petite voiture il ya un facteur
3 mais il n'y a pas un facteur 50 alors
que en ce qui concerne les émissions
d'origine agricole vous pouvez avoir
leurs 50 peut-être pas mais vous pouvez
voir un facteur 10 très facilement sur
un certain nombre de processus en
fonction de la température de la paix
dauphin du sol voilà donc cesser
et c'est très compliqué et du coup comme
c'est très compliqué d'avoir
l'inventaire de départ parce que c'est
rsa dépend énormément du
de des conditions c'est plus difficile
d'identifier les marges de manoeuvre
puisque si vous savez pas exactement
d'où partait c'est plus difficile de
savoir dans quelle direction il faut il
faut partir ya des trucs vous êtes sûr
de votre coup par exemple si vous
diminuez je veux dire mais si vous
diminuez la taille du troupeau
toutes choses égales par ailleurs vous
êtes absolument certains individus et
les émissions
mais si vous voulez optimisé
techniquement c'est compliqué parce
qu'en fait la seule vraie manière de
savoir s' est instrumenté par tous
c'est la seule manière
une des manières de diminuer les
émissions des effluents cd métallisé
donc ça c'est quelque chose là vous êtes
sûr va aller dans la bonne direction
c'est clair maintenant le pouvoir
méthanogène des effluents il n'est pas
très élevé et donc très souvent
l'équation économique des méthaniseurs
fait que vous pour que ça marche vous
êtes obligés d'y rajouter des cultures
dédiées
et là ça devient ça devient plus
discutable on va dire
est-ce qu'on peut estimer qu'en fait le
fait que produire de la viande dans les
décennies futures va être de plus en
plus compliqué que changement climatique
le problème de consommation de viande
qu'on fait actuellement qui est 30
pourtant le problème va se résoudre tout
seul ce qu'on peut dire que c'est une
bonne nouvelle en gros moi je préférais
qui se résolvent de manière organisée
vous avez vu qu'on a plusieurs problèmes
sur les bras qu'on doit résoudre en même
temps le premier problème c'est que dans
un monde sobres en énergie la taille de
la population urbaine est excessive une
fois que je vous ai dit ça ça veut dire
qu'il va bien falloir qu'on trouve à
occuper des gens dans les campagnes
bah oui
logique
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme ressource dans
les campagnes aujourd'hui ya plus de
mines n'a plus beaucoup il ya la terre
il ya la forêt
le soleil est enfin là il ya un certain
nombre de trucs donc ça veut dire qu'il
va falloir occuper il va falloir trouver
des activités autour de tout ça
dans le même temps il ya effectivement
aujourd'hui trop de cash en france
si on veut fortement baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
la quadrature du cercle consiste à faire
bosser plus de gens avec moi de vache
exactement ça que ça veut dire est l'une
des contreparties c'est pour ça que je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure le prix de la
nourriture va remonter
c'est obligé le prix de la nourriture va
finir par remonter aujourd'hui on paie
une nourriture qui n'est peut-être pas
mondialisé dans son lieu de production
mais qui est mondialisé dans sa chaîne
de valeur quand il voit les phosphates
ils sont au maroc les le début de la
chaîne des engrais c'est les gisements
de gaz iranien et le oui c'est les
emballages qui permettent d'aller mettre
la viande dans le supermarché c'est une
plate forme pétrolière qui sont chez
paou donc le
la chaîne de valeur de l'agriculture est
totalement mondialisé même pour les
élevages qui sont le lot qu
on
sait c sa la quadrature du cercle c'est
qu'il va falloir remettre plus de valeur
dans des exploitations avec moins de
bêtes ça ne passera pas sans un
mécanisme collectif
qui fasse monter les prix au kilo de la
production primaire
c'est obligé donc et un point qui
convergent avec ça c'est que vous pouvez
pas demander à un secteur qui a pas
d'argent d'innover
donc si on veut que l'agriculture innove
c'est à dire face des choses différente
de ce qu'elle fait aujourd'hui et bouge
vite ça c'est aussi convergent avec le
le fait que ça doit recevoir plus
d'argent
tout ça va l'énergie abondante a fait
perdre les agriculteurs et gagner tous
les gens qui sont à laval c'est à dire
les transformateurs les distributeurs et
les actionnaires de tout ce beau monde
la sobriété énergétique devrait et toi
si il faut l'organiser comme ça parce
que sinon ça va se faire par craquements
produire quelque part le mécanisme
inverse
alors juste petite information il ya
autant de personnes dans la salle que
que deux personnes qui nous suivent en
direct sur le live sur nous sur nos
réseaux et j'en profite pour prendre des
questions qui sont arrivés indirectement
sur sur les personnes qui nous écoutent
derrière leur écran
donc une personne demande quels sont les
risques pour la production agricole de
la diminution de la production de gaz
naturel
la diminution
aujourd'hui
donc je voulais dire l'augmentation très
forte des rendements céréaliers
qui sont nécessaires pour toutes les
bêtes qui sont nourris autrement que
essentiellement avec des pâturages
c'est un c'est le résultat de la
mécanisation et de la fabrication des
engrais azotés et des phytosanitaires et
des phosphates
avec la baisse de la disponibilité en
gaz on n'aura alors pas tout de suite
parce que du gaz si on se fiche du
changement climatique y en a encore pour
quelques décennies
mais enfin je dis rien encore pour 20 ou
30 ans en quantité croissante wave un an
on va dire
15 ans 20 ans et puis après ça baisse
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui se passe à
ce moment là alors je ne dis pas on peut
préserver les engrais longtemps parce
qu'on diminue de chauffage au gaz on
peut jeux d'eau voilà le gaz il a
plusieurs types d'usagés sert à la
production électrique alors dans la
production électrique malheureusement il
a plutôt tendance à augmenter parce que
la ruée vers l'éolien et le solaire
demande des sources complémentaires pour
garantir l'approvisionnement et cette
source complémentaire c'est le gaz donc
vous avez en france il se trouve que
l'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques et éoliennes étaient
destinés dans la loi de programmation de
l'énergie que hollande a fait voter à
remplacer du nucléaire et pas à
remplacer des combustibles fossiles donc
ça c'est neutre en ce qui concerne les
émissions de co2 puisque le nucléaire
fait pas de co2 il peut avoir plein les
inconvénients mais pas celui-là et
l'éolien et le solaire directement font
pas de co2 non plus donc vouloir
remplacer du nucléaire l'éolien du
solaire s'est raisonnablement d'autres
par contre dans les pays qui avaient du
charbon et du gaz si vous remplacez le
charbon ou le gaz par d'éolien du
solaire ça fait baisser les émissions
c'est comme ça qu'un certain nombre de
pays qui ne veulent pas de nucléaire
font baisser leurs émissions mais sauf à
décider que ce genre de conférence ne se
tient pas la nuit quand ya pas de vent
et bien donc voilà où que le train donc
la danse de la conférence et sous
réserve qu'ils aient du vent bon très
bien
si vous voulez pas de ce genre
d'organisation et on ne veut plus
aujourd'hui de ce genre d'organisation
je vous rappelle qu'il ya quelques
siècles et bien la farine et évolue
quand il y avait du vent quand et pas de
vent il ait pas de farine alors
heureusement la farine ce stock
même si à des charançons alors que
l'électricité ne se stocke pas son
principal problème donc si on veut
conserver une société organisée en
fonction des horaires qui est la société
dans laquelle on vit aujourd'hui vos
gamins vont à l'école qui est du vent au
pas devant vous allez au travail qui est
du vent ou pas devant le train par
alleurs va normalement qui est du vent
ou pas devant votre voiture par qui est
du vent ou pas de vent donc en gros nous
vivons dans une société dans laquelle
tout est organisé en fonction des
horaires ça ça demande un système qui
soit totalement prévisibles et donc dans
un système totalement prévisibles vous
ne pouvez pas avoir une fourniture qui
soit imprévisible et non garantie donc
tous les systèmes électriques dans
lesquelles on voit se développer
fortement des modes qui ne sont pas
garanties donc l'éolien et le solaire
voit également se développer du gaz
parce que c'est ce qui est moins cher à
construire
donc tout ça peut revenir à la question
qui est 40% du gaz mondiales aujourd'hui
est utilisée pour faire de l'électricité
la fraction qui est utilisé pour faire
des engrais est beaucoup plus faible
donc la bonne question c'est est-ce que
combien de temps est-ce qu'il y aura du
gaz pour faire des engrais dans un monde
dans lequel on dopantes le gaz
l'électricité voilà voilà une des
questions j'ai pas la réponse à
mes clairement aujourd'hui le l'alchimie
des la chimie dans leurs dépens c'est la
raison pour laquelle je fais partie des
gens qui pensent que
l'hydrogène si on commence à en faire
par électrolyse avec de l'électricité
pas carbonées dans les deux usages
prioritaires qu'il faut avoir de ces
d'hydrogène il ya sûrement pas de
voiture et sur ma patte avions il ya la
fabrication d'engrais et la fabrication
d'acier l'acier aujourd'hui se fabrique
avec du charbon un champion spécial qui
s'appelle du coq
ça et mais plein de co2 la fabrication
d'acier sans émettre de co2 se peut se
faire avec de l'hydrogène
et la fabrication d'engrais sans co2
peut également c'est avec de l'hydrogène
qu'on aurait obtenu par électrolyse avec
de l'électricité elle-même décarbonés
donc et ça c'est beaucoup plus
prioritaire que de pouvoir aller aux
seychelles en avions
donc le premier le premier rideau gêne
qu'on produit devrait aller dans ces
deux applications là et déjà quand on
voit la quantité d'électricité qu'il
faut pour faire ces d'autres clara déjà
si on fait ça c'est bien
vous êtes partout présenté comme étant
très pro nucléaire
et vous venez simplement il ya quelques
minutes de prononcer le mot de toute la
soirée
est-ce que vous pouvez en dire un peu
plus parce que on est un peu
des échéances qui sont importantes et
des défis merci
le nucléaire il n'est pas un
déterminant du cadre il est indéterminée
il est un élément de discussion dans
qu'est ce qu'on fait à partir de
maintenant c'est pour ça qu'en général
quand je fais une intervention gens
parlent pas beaucoup dans le cadre de
l'intervention parce que ça pose pas le
décor ce qui pose le décor c'est la
façon dont les combustibles fossiles qui
représente 80% de l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial
organisé la société mondiale et en
particulier le pétrole qui est l'énergie
reine du 20e siècle c'est le pétrole a
fait le 20e siècle s'il n'y avait pas eu
de pétrole y aurait pas eu le 20e siècle
parce que c'est notamment lui qui a fait
le système de transport qui est la
vascularisation de l'économie mondiale
donc le nucléaire j'en parle jamais dans
la partie liminaire des interventions çà
devient un sujet de discussion dans
qu'est ce qu'on fait à partir de
maintenant
c'est pas nécessairement le choix des
journalistes qui me font l'honneur de
parler de moi qui pense que j'ai que ça
à présent à la cervelle sauf à ce que
j'ai été un très gros hypocrites dans la
première partie de cette intervention
week et quelques autres petits trucs qui
me trotte dans la tête
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça qu'est ce
que je pense du nucléaire je pense que
pour reprendre une expression que j'ai
déjà utilisé il s'agit d'un parachute
ventrale
un parachute ventrale c'est un parachute
qui est moins bien que le parachute
dorsale est moins gros moins efficace et
rapide et voilà et vous vous en servez
quand vous êtes déjà pas très bien c'est
à dire que le parachute dorsales a
décidé de vous jouer un sale tour mais
ça vous évite de vous écraser au sol le
nucléaire c'est exactement pareil c'est
un truc c'est moins confortable à
utiliser du pétrole du gaz ou du charbon
tout compliquer c'est plus sophistiquées
ces terres à sa demande des compétences
plus pointus ces voix là mais c'est un
truc qui présente de l'intérêt à partir
du moment où on a décidé que les
combustibles fossiles on voulait plus en
entendre parler
c'est bien dans ce cadre là que je me
situe alors quels sont ses avantages et
ses inconvénients pour essayer d'être un
peu rapide son principal avantage c'est
sa compacité vous avez alors l'énergie
nucléaire ce exploitants casse en deux
un noyau d'un métal qui s'appelle
l'uranium donc ce n'est pas une énergie
fossile c'est une énergie qui dépend
d'un métal disponible en quantité
limitée mais ce métal ne résulte pas de
la vie ancienne donc de temps en temps
il ya des gens qui disent le nucléaire
c'est une énergie dans c'est pas faux
cils c'est pas un truc qui résulte de la
vie ancienne par contre ça utilise un
métal et tous les métaux sont
disponibles en quantité limitée
l'uranium comme les autres et cette
réaction nucléaire consiste à faire
faire une indigestion un noyau d'uranium
en lui envoyant à neutrons dedans
noyaux d'uranium absorbe les neutrons et
se casse en deux comme le type qui a
trop mangé dans la vie de brian je sais
pas si vous avez vu tout les tripes qui
lui sortent au restaurant ben c'est
pareil le noyau d'uranium 235 qui lui
arrive la même chose y mange le dos rond
il a le bit qui explose il se casse en
deux et les deux morceaux dans lesquels
ils se cassent s'appelle des produits de
fission et c'est ça qui vont donner les
déchets nucléaires les plus en perdant
et puis
il ya également des deux troncs qui se
libèrent qui vont aller qui vont être
mangés par d'autres noyaux d'uranium
c'est comme ça que la réaction en chaîne
se fait et puis ça fait plein d'énergie
dans la fission d'un gramme d'uranium
vous avez autant d'énergie que dans la
combustion d'une tonne de pétrole 1
gramme d'uranium une tonne de pétrole
donc c'est une énergie extrêmement
compact c'est ça son intérêt principal
donc vous pouvez avoir de très grandes
quantités d'énergie avec des tout petits
volumes et des toutes petites quantités
de matière alors ça ça a deux avantages
principaux derrière et par ailleurs ça
fait pas de co2 puisque casser un noyau
en deux c'est pas oxydée du carbone
c'est pas pareil donc ça ça veut dire
que derrière vous allez pouvoir avoir
des centrales électriques qui
globalement prennent peu de place pour
produire beaucoup d'électricité et vous
allez effectivement avoir des
cochonneries derrière qui s'appelle des
déchets nucléaires mais comme vous
utilisez très peu de matière en entrée
des déchets nucléaires vous en avais pas
beaucoup en quantité
aujourd'hui vous avez la totalité des
déchets de haute activité et longue
durée de vie donc les emmerder très
emmerdant à ce qu'on veut mettre dans le
sous-sol à burlats qui ont été générés
par quarante ans d'exploitation du parc
français ils tiennent dans un gymnase
voilà ça vous donne une idée donc c'est
effectivement des saloperies mais il y
en a pas beaucoup
le
jeu
les inconvénients du nucléaire sont
sa demande des technologies enfin des
compétences pointues c'est à dire que
vous pouvez pas passer demain matin de
charpentier à constructeur de centrales
nucléaires et compliqué
la deuxième chose c'est que sa demande
c'est très capitalistique sa demande de
très gros investissements au départ et
comme toutes les choses très
capitalistique les agriculteurs ici et
le savent alors modeste échelle derrière
il faut vous ayez de un horizon de temps
important devant vous pour être sûr que
les investissements vous allez faire
vous allez avoir un cadre stable pour
pouvoir les rentabiliser
donc le nucléaire demande des horizons
de temps qui sont longs
pour des raisons économiques
le troisième inconvénients que ça c'est
que ça
ça ne fait que de l'électricité donc
c'est un des inconvénients donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut pouvoir derrière
utiliser l'électricité à la place du
pétrole s'est pas toujours ses voitures
font électrifier les voitures et s'il y
aura assez de métaux pour faire des
batteries etc
les inconvénients que ça n'a pas même si
vous allez sauter en l'air c'est que ces
monstrueuses en plus dangereux que le
reste ça n'est pas monstrueux
heureusement plus dangereux que le reste
vous avez un une instance onusienne qui
existe depuis 1955 qui s'appelle le
comité scientifique des nations unies
pour les effets des rayonnements
ionisants donc en gros c'est la même
chose que le giec mais ça s'occupe des
études médicales qui disent ce qui se
passe quand les gens sont soumis à des
rayonnements ionisants existe depuis
1955 geiq depuis 88 qui a fait plein de
publication et notamment un retour
d'expérience sur fukushima et tchernobyl
tchernobyl et de loups et pas du tout
l'accident industriel le pire de tous
les temps c'est très très largement
enfoncés par bhopal si vous avez déjà
entendu parler de l'accident de bhopal
qui est un accident du site chimique qui
a fait de l'ordre de 5000 morts et des
blessés avec des séquelles à vie par
dizaines de milliers
tchernobyl a fait 50 morts instantanée
si je fais les choses très très rustique
et
6000 cas de cancers à la thyroïde qui
feront quelques centaines de morts
prématurées voilà donc c'est un drame du
tout en train de dire que c'est une
plaisanterie mais si vous remettez ça un
perspective d'autres accidents
industriels si on dit qu'on arrête le
nucléaire à cause de tchernobyl alors on
arrête tout de suite lâché dit on arrête
tout de suite les barrages on arrête
tout de suite les automobiles qui font
un million de morts par an dans le monde
tous les ans on arrête tout de suite le
tabac serait ce qu on devrait arrêter
tout de suite et on arrête même tout de
suite les piscines qui font 400 morts
par an en france
400 morts par an les piscines j'espère
qu'il ya personne dans la salle qui a
perdu un jeu d'enfant noyé dans une
piscine vois ça a failli arriver donc
n'en est pas qu aux autres donc le voilà
donc cessé quand on remet en perspective
le nucléaire il faut pas y renoncer pour
des raisons de dangerosité par contre
comme c'est un engin qui est très lourd
et très inerte il ne faut pas croire que
il suffit d'en faire pour être
débarrassée de tous les emmerdements que
j'ai évoquées
il n'y a rien de plus faux que ça voilà
donc de ne pas en faire c'est se priver
d'une marge de manoeuvre utile en faire
ça fait 5 ou 10 % du chemin
ce qui est déjà ce qui est très
important parce que le chemin est très
raide mais c'est
ça des vitres a pas la sobriété et pour
finir là-dessus si vous avez suivi la
primaire des écologistes
moi je les regardais j'ai regardé
beaucoup d'intérêt le premier débat
où il y avait les quatre là et il y
avait une des candidates qui a dit celle
qui est par ailleurs été
ouvertement partisan de la décroissance
qui a dit je ne fermerai pas
prématurément il centrales en france
voilà c'est je pense que ça résume assez
bien
le le le fait qu'on peut très bien être
conscient des limites et se dire
va vraiment falloir transpirer et dans
cette transpiration le nucléaire se
range plutôt des trucs pertinents plutôt
que des trucs dont il faut se
débarrasser en plus des efforts qu'on
doit faire sur le reste
vous avez à deux reprises parlé d'un dit
un gros mot
la décroissance
si vous alliez dire vaches
comme vous l'avez souligné ça a été
porté par delphine batho pendant la
primaire des écologistes
vous seriez vous arrivez président de la
république quelles sont les mesures que
vous prenez pour mettre en place 3 je la
met pas en place parce que je pense
qu'elle est invendable en tant que tel
je pense que delphine batho a tort
d'utiliser ce mot est la raison de
penser que c'est dans ce cadre physique
là qu'on va devoir raisonnée et je pense
qu'elle a tort d'utiliser vos pourquoi
je pense qu'elle a tort d'utiliser le
mot parce que vous avez eu une telle
inertie dans le sens inverse on a
tellement longtemps assimilés croissance
à progrès que je pense que le temps qu
elle explique que c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut raisonner son mandat est
terminé au revoir madame donc je pense
que c'est pas un beau qu'il faut
utiliser parce que
beaucoup trop connoté beaucoup trop
chargé
on peut l'utiliser dans des débats mais
je veux dire dans un dans un programme
présidentiel je pense que
trop de malentendus autour de ça je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure je suis pas allé
jusqu'au bout de mon raisonnement mais
j'aurais dû en ce qui concerne le
pétrole on va déjà on est déjà en
décroissance subie en europe alors
j'aurais pu y rajouter que c'est
également vrai pour le gaz le gaz qui
est une énergie régionales parce que il
se transporte beaucoup plus mal que le
pétrole parce qu'il est 1000 fois moins
denses parce qu'il est gaz de
la mer du nord a passé son pic en 2005
et enfin le charbon qui est une énergie
aussi locales régionales parce que c'est
un pont d'hérault solide et qu'un pont
d'hérault solide ça se transporte pas
bien l'europe a passé son pic dans les
années 50 donc en fait en europe en ce
qui concerne l'approvisionnement en
charbon on est en déclin depuis bien
avant que le climat soit un sujet
l'approvisionnement en gaz est en déclin
depuis le milieu des années 2000 et
l'approvisionnement en pétrole à cause
du pic conventionnelle mondiale est
aussi en déclin depuis le milieu des
années 2000 ce qui fait que
l'approvisionnement énergétique européen
est en déclin depuis 2006 donc le parc
de machines en europe est en déclin
depuis 2006 et donc la production
industrielle est en déclin et donc le
pib il est pas en déclin mais c'est
parce qu'il ya des artefacts comptable
dans tous les sens et effectivement un
certain nombre d'entre vous commencent à
trouver les fins de mois plus difficiles
ceci va avec cela donc en fait je pense
que la décroissance elle est déjà là
donc c'est pour ça que moi je ne
prononcerai pas le beau
et o'shea project du reste on est en
train de réfléchir à un plan de
décarbonation de l'économie française
qu'on appelle le plan de transformation
de l'économie française et on a décidé
qu'on ne parlerait pas d'argent vous
dire comment ça il s'en fout ça serve
ouais on va faire des économies sans
parler d'argent en fait on va regarder
ce qu'on doit faire vous moi tout le
monde dans un monde qui doivent
décarbonée c'est quoi les activités
qu'on doit avoir c'est quoi les
objectifs qu'on doit viser en termes
physiques donc de logements qu'on doit
transformer la façon dont on se déplace
donc de vélos électriques on doit
construire le nombre de voitures
électriques pour doit construire deux
camions électriques on doit construire
le nombre de vaches qui doit élever etc
les métiers que les gens vont avoir
besoin de faire est ce que les on aura
toujours besoin d'opérateurs chez danone
ou es ce que vous avez tous devoir
embaucher des gens qui vont faire des
yaourts chez vous voilà est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on a besoin de
faire et c'est seulement derrière qu'on
va se poser la question de sa veux dire
quoi en terme économique c'est dans ce
sens là qu'on a envie de raisonner
mais donc la décroissance elle est déjà
là donc pour moi elle est pas à vendre
c'est une donnée du problème ce qui est
à vendre ses les projets qui sont
cohérents avec ça
il faut cent us à la difficulté de la
faire c'est qu'il faut arriver à trouver
la campagne marketing pour quelque chose
qui embarque la décroissance 100-200
sentir que c'est un objectif en tant que
tel je ne suis pas vraiment un objectif
en tant que tel et voilà c'est ça qui va
être difficile alors deuxième truc qui
va être difficile si j'en reviens à des
termes enfin des éléments strictement
économique c'est que le pib c'est la
base fiscale l'essentiel des
prélèvements obligatoires sont assis sur
des composantes du pib les charges
sociales sur les salaires c'est une
composante du pib enfin les salaires
c'est une composante du pib est ce que c
est revenu l'impôt sur les sociétés
c'est à la tva tout ça c'est des impôts
qui sont assis sur des morceaux du pib
les seuls impôts qui sont pas assis sur
des composantes du pib c'est les impôts
sur les stocks donc les impôts sur les
télés les impôts sur le foncier etc et
des impôts comme ça on a très peu
donc l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
le monde politique est tétanisé par
cette idée de décroissance et que ça
peut immédiatement dire problème
budgétaire
immédiatement
donc on aura beaucoup de mal à vendre en
tant que tel
il faut il faut se creuser la cervelle
pour savoir comment est ce qu'on arrive
à vendre quelque chose qui embarque de
la sobriété et qui fait qu on a le
regard qui se fixent ailleurs et pas sur
cet élément là je vois dernier parallèle
que je pourrais prendre que je prends
souvent c'est si toute votre vie vous
êtes intéressé à la vitesse à laquelle
vous courrez et vous avez couru de plus
en plus vite ça devient très très
pénible de continuer à vous intéresser à
la vie qu'est la vitesse à laquelle vous
courrez quand vous courrez y ait moins
en moins vite
vous n'aimez pas ça en général oui faut
essayer de trouver autre chose comme
point de fixation notre attention
à tout ça ça a l'air d'être de l'appel
théorie mais quand même c'est ça cahier
des charges de là je crois vraiment à
l'occasion des charges delà de la
réflexion
allez je vais reprendre une question qui
nous arrive de sur les réseaux sociaux
de plus en plus de familles cherchent
l'autonomie alimentaire sur leurs terres
est ce un rêve de gogos ou une possible
contribution significative à l'échelle
du pays
dès qu'on est en ville c'est un rêve de
beaucoup
pour les gens qui habitent
dans rodez même
je pense que c'est pas sur leur balcon
qui vont même s'ils sont vegan
cultiver tout ce qui leur est nécessaire
pour manger toute l'année patate et
c'est
ce qui a du sens en fait c'est 2d
spécialisés les régions agricoles
aujourd'hui un camion sur trois en
france transportent quelque chose qui se
mange je l' ai dit tout à l'heure sans
camion les villes meurent de faim l'île
de francs dont des spécialisés les
régions agricoles ça veut dire que le
kilométrage moyen parcouru par un
aliment avant d'arriver dans une
assiette ils baissent
donc ça veut dire que faut remettre des
vaches et des cochons dans la bosse pas
trop
ça veut dire que
quand je disais tout à l'heure dans la
baisse du cheptel bovin pourquoi je
pense que vous allez pousser un ouf de
soulagement
l'essentiel du cheptel qu'il faut faire
diminuer c'est celui qui est hors sol
toute l'année c'est celui là qu'il faut
faire diminuer en premier il faut
laisser en premier le pâturage sans
compter que le pâturage est souvent une
manière de valoriser des surfaces qu'on
aura du mal à valoriser autrement
donc là
le
mais il faut essayer effectivement de et
dans l'ancien temps toutes les villes
avaient leurs ceintures maraîchères
parce que les villes se sont souvent
installées dans des zones de plaines
fertiles
et beaucoup en tout cas et il y avait
une ceinture maraîchère qui servait à
nourrir la ville sur une partie de ce
qu'elle mangeait des patates jusqu'au
salade ça il faudrait idéalement essayer
d'en reconstituer mais maintenant à la
place des ceintures maraîchères et les
pavillons dans qu'est ce qu'on en fait
enfin voilà donc on a un certain nombre
de problèmes pas évident du tout
à résoudre mais globalement il faut
aller dans le sens de la
déspécialisation des régions agricoles
et dans le sens du l'autonomie stricto
sensu est un bon mois qui me fait très
peur parce que il ya un exemple dans le
passé d'autonomie ça s'appelle les
sociétés tribales et en général c'est
des gens qui passaient leur temps à se
faire la guerre
le je vous rappelle que le grand projet
européen
qui était portée par les pères
fondateurs un bonnet gaspille rischmann
c'était un projet des changes pour qu'on
se connaît c'est donc qu'on n'ait pas
peur de l'autre et qu'on se tape pas
dessus et c'est pour ça que l'europe
s'est retrouvé à faire une telle
proportion du commerce jusqu'à la nausée
aujourd'hui jusqu'à la nausée
aujourd'hui où on a fait sauter toutes
les barrières toutes les entraves au
commerce et aujourd'hui on pense plus de
concurrence en fait on a confondu la fin
et les moyens la fin c'était de vivre en
paix les moyens c'était que les gens se
connaissent et donc qu'il fasse du
commerce ensemble et puis maintenant on
a oublié que l'objectif c'était de vivre
en paix mais c'est c'était exactement ça
donc en fait l'autonomie c'est pas
quelque chose d'essentiel ce qui est
essentiel c'est de dépendre de gens qui
ont besoin de vous
attend vous dépendez de gens qui ont
besoin de vous
je n'ai pas nécessairement voilà le
l'autonomie
tous les gens qui sont pour l'autonomie
je sais pas si sûr pour l'autonomie
sexuelle par exemple
donc donc l'autonomie a ses limites
c'est un mot qui a été extrêmement
extrêmement galvaudé vous
vous avez un domaine par exemple dans
lequel les élus ont que les élus adore
c'est l'autonomie énergétique aussi
souvent l'autonomie énergétique consiste
à voir que sur la commune la
consommation annuelle d'électricité est
égale à la production annuelle de trois
éoliennes et on dit ah ça y est je suis
autonome
rien à voir
l'électricité de l'éolienne est pas plus
locale que celle du barrage de serre
ponçon donc
mais mais c'est voilà donc c'est pour
dire l'autonomie faut s'en méfier il
faut avoir besoin des autres le moins
important c'est la résilience pour moi
c'est à dire être dans un système qui a
une forme de solidité du système il ya
un système qui est une forme de solidité
est un système toujours qui a une forme
qui composantes collective et qu'il ya
une composante des changes
moi je voulais vous demander comment
donc pour en revenir à un point de
croissance comment vous pouvez en fait
lancé cette décroissance quand il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont beaucoup
de pouvoir en fait à travers le lobbying
notamment qui ont tout intérêt à ce
qu'on pollue entre guillemets donc qui
font du business sur 7 sur cette
escalade sur 7 sur cette production de
co2 finalement donc
ils ont pas tellement d'intérêt parce
que eux qui dit en fait baisse delà de
la consommation baissent ils vont perdre
forcément énormément d'argent et j'ai du
mal à voir comment on pourrait diminuer
alors que c'est eux qui derrière à
mettre la pression sur les politiques
justement qu'on reste donne ses modèles
les entreprises je connais un peu
puisque c'est mon secteur de clientèle
dans mon activité au quotidien c'est ces
deux notamment de faire du conseil
les entreprises ninove que sous la
contrainte et elle ne change que sous la
contrainte donc il faut pas se raconter
10 kg pas se raconter d'histoires il n'y
a que la contrainte qui fait bouger une
entreprise c'est quoi la contrainte
c'est que ses clients changent
d'exigence c'est que des concurrents
arrivent c'est que ses actionnaires
change d'exigence c'est que les pouvoirs
publics changent d'exigence où c'est que
les employés change d'exigence donc pour
faire évoluer une entreprise faut
s'intéresser à ce qu'elle vend et à ses
clients en les clients général seydou il
faut s'intéresser à ses salariés il ya
des fois où les salariés peuvent faire
changer d'entreprise chez vous donner
des exemples après on peut évidemment
s'intéresser à la puissance publique
puissance publique me faire changer
l'entreprise en l'obligeant à être
soumises à des contraintes qu'ils
n'aient vu qu'elle n'avait pas avant
et on peut s'intéresser à ses
actionnaires mais en général c'est plus
difficile aujourd'hui parce que les
actionnaires c'est toutes les personnes
dans cette salle qui ont de l'assurance
vie de l'assurance vie seul
bon les autres c'est parce qu'ils savent
que je vais les allumer dont qui n'osent
pas lever la main
tous les gens ici qui ont de
l'assurance-vie possèdent peu ou prou
des actions d'entreprises
donc les actionnaires c'est vous c'est
pas le marché c'est vous vous qu'est ce
que vous faites quand vous avez
d'assurance vie ou dit [ __ ] ça me
rapporte 2,5 classe afin de leur
apporter 1,5 ça pouvait me rapporter 1,8
ce serait bien quand même en tenant ce
raisonnement vous venez très exactement
de tenir le raisonnement qui permet à
l'entreprise de justifier qu'elle doit
continuer à polluer pour gagner plus de
pognon c'est très exactement ça que vous
faites donc à chaque fois que vous
arbitrez vos placements personnels
d'assurance vie en fonction du rendement
vous poussez les entreprises qui ont
émis les actions et les obligations que
vous détenez comme épargnants
à se fichent de l'environnement
c'est désagréable d'entendre ça
donc mais c'est très exactement ça donc
le don donc aller par les actionnaires
c'est compliqué alors ça peut se faire
quand même vous avez aujourd'hui par
exemple des applications qui permettent
de savoir quelle est l'empreinte carbone
de votre épargne
on a un client à carbone 4 qui fait sa
une application qui s'appelle litas et
qui est édité par une société qui
s'appelle rift avant que ce soit la
version photoshop sur les deux mais je
crois que c'est ça et
non l'application s'appelle naïveté
sellita la société j'ai pu enfin bref
c'est l'un des deux je confonds toujours
et ça vous dit enfin vous lui dites oui
j'ai des fonds communs de placement de
saulcy machin vous donner les noms et ça
vous dit voilà l'empreinte carbone de
votre épargne étant alors ça ça fait
bouger quelques actionnaires pas
beaucoup parce que l'essentiel se
contrefoutent de l'empreinte carbone de
leur épargner regarde juste que ça
raconte
la faire bouger les salariés c'est déjà
un peu plus facile notamment chez les
jeunes aujourd'hui j'ai de plus en plus
fréquemment des témoignages de chefs
d'entreprise qui me disent l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles je commence à
être obligé de m'intéressait vraiment
sérieusement au problème c'est que je
reçoit en entretien de recrutement enfin
moi pas moi mais mes équipes reçoivent
en entretien de recrutement des gens qui
me questionnent là dessus et plus les
gens ont le choix
est plus évidemment leur le le fait de
tenir compte de leur opinion est
important parce que si les gens ont le
choix et que vous faites pas ce qu'il en
playboy iront voir ailleurs
donc pour les compétences un peu
recherché mais pas nécessairement des
cadres par exemple les ouvriers dans
l'industrie est bien le fait que les
gens soient sensibles à ce genre de
sujet et 10 mois ça compte pour moi
c'est quelque chose qui peut faire
bouger une entreprise
après ce qui fait évidemment bouger une
entreprise et ses clients
donc j'ai envie de dire la première
responsabilité de quelqu'un qui pense
que ce problème est important c'est sa
responsabilité de consommateurs on peut
pas tout faire comme consommateurs par
exemple comme consommateur vous changez
pas la composition d'un parc électrique
dans un pays
vous pouvez évidemment arbitré vos
propres choix en fonction de parcs du
parc électrique du pays ça c'est clair
mais par contre vous ne changez pas à
vous tout seul camp conservateur le parc
électrique d'un pays donc ça c'est un
acte qui dit vous pouvez par contre
changer votre chaudière
où vous pouvez décider de modifier votre
régime alimentaire de cas des trucs que
vous pouvez faire et puis des trucs que
vous pouvez pas faire mais vous avez
quand même un rôle important
comme disait coluche il suffit que ça
s'achète pas pour que ça se vende pas
le la dernière chose qui fait bouger une
entreprise c'est la puissance publique
et ça c'est notre rôle de citoyens
mais il faut bien voir que notre rôle de
citoyens ont larbitre avec notre rôle de
salariés c'est à dire que quand on veut
faire des misères à une entreprise ont
fait par ricochet parfois des misères à
ses salariés et donc des fois ça nous
retient à juste titre d'avoir envie de
faire des misères à une entreprise parce
qu'on n'a pas envie de faire des misères
aux salariés
ça dépend lesquels mais généralement
n'ont
en tout cas pas par principe donc si on
achète moins de voiture et qu'on monte
moins de pneus les salariés de l'usiné
goodyear ils ont moins de boulot et on
dira c'est pas sympa pour donc on
on
donc la pression de la puissance
publique est aussi quelque chose qui
fait bouger les entreprises je peux vous
dire par exemple dans le domaine de la
construction il ya une réglementation
qui vient de changer et qui oblige
maintenant à tenir compte de l'empreinte
carbone des produits de construction
et à limiter cette dernière c'est en
train de modifier de manière rapide les
techniques qui sont utilisés par les
constructeurs
ça n'empêche pas qu'il continue à
construire est artificialisé les terres
si c'est ça qui nous apporte mais par
contre ça modifie quand même la manière
dont ils anticipent rennes donc voilà en
gros les marges de manoeuvre donc c'est
pas exact de dire qu'on ne peut rien
faire en ce qui concerne les entreprises
on ne peut jamais rien faire tout seul
et tout de suite ça c'est très très
clair
collectivement ou dans certains cadres
et dans la durée c'est pas vrai
il ya capable
peu importants
on déjeune chez un petit peu je vous
remercie beaucoup
de vos interventions ça fait un moment
que permis d'être un peu plus un peu
moins bête et mémé ça m'amène à une
question justement le la question je
parle pas bien devant pardon donc je
voulais jeu j'espère vous avez entendu
herman mon remerciements le partage de
votre intelligence et un plaisir
qu'il soit ou pas vous êtes
polytechnicien en lien avec le nucléaire
c'est un bonheur de vous entendre vous
exprimer avec humour et clarté et
adaptabilité justement et ça me fait
poser une question quand même qui me
taraude
il ya une pertinence dans la
compréhension de la complexité
énergétique que vous détenez que vous
avez amélioré au fur et à mesure des
années graphique progresser dans le
temps et dans leur pertinence
et dans la salle
combien de personnes sont compétentes
dans une toute petite part de
compréhension de la manière d'utiliser
l'énergie de la gérez vous parler de
décroissance mais on a tous l'habitude
du confort plutôt est typiquement dans
le confort il ya une absurdité d'emploi
de l'énergie au lieu de couper son
radiateur pendant qu'on fait tourner sa
plaque électrique par exemple qui
permettrait de suffire avec 3 kilowatt
heure ben on prend six kilos edf et on
met les deux en même temps
alors que ça aurait pu fonctionner est
ce que vous croyez pas que alors vous
vous avez un grand savoir puisque vous
êtes polytechnicien cerveau qui avait pu
briller qui a pu avancer mais est ce
qu'il faudrait pas qu'on
alors vous le faites mais pensez vous
qu'ils auraient une solution dans l'idée
de rendre les gens plus intelligents
dans leur compréhension de l'énergie
est ce que la question a un sens oui oui
je comprends très bien en fait
on peut être polytechnicien et ne pas
savoir faire cuire un oeuf au plat
j'avais un copain qui étaient dans ce
cas là est par ailleurs n'avoir
strictement
je dis pas ça pour moi parce que je sais
absolument pas si tu mets et n'avoir
absolument aucune notion humaine j'ai
envie enfin de rien comprendre au
comportement de ses semblables vous
savez pour rentrer à l'x on nous demande
de résoudre des équations pas de
comprendre comment fonctionnent les
hommes donc enfin l'humanité
là la question que vous posez
elle relève beaucoup plus des sujets du
comportement de la sociologie de comment
on fait pour donner finalement envie aux
gens de faire autrement que ce qui
quelque part on n'est pas loin des gens
qui doivent se
désaccoutumer d'une drogue ou son nez on
est un peu dans ce registre là et donc
on est dans des registres qui sont pas
du tout ceux des sciences exactes
on est dans le registre de l'affectif de
l'émotion de l'envi de ces c'est évident
qu'on peut pas vendre la privation on
n'a jamais vendu la privation est du
reste quand on a dit aux poilus allez
donc vous battre on leur a pas vendu
vous allez être dans les tranchées
boueuses et qu'est ce que ça va être
merdique on leur a dit vous allez sauver
l'honneur de la france et qu'est ce que
ça va être bien donc alors que la
réalité c'est qu'ils étaient dans les
tranchées boueuses et c'est quand même
assez merdique mans donc là là on est
c'est exactement pareil
ça renvoie la question qui a été posée
tout à l'heure il faut essayer de voir
où est ce qu'on peut avoir du désir
immédiat pardonnez moi cette expression
dans le fait de changer notre rapport à
la matérialité
alors je vais prendre un exemple à la
con vraiment la composent mais
à la suite d'une histoire que j'habite
en banlieue parisienne
et
moi je veux des place par les transports
en commun mais j'aurais pu me déplacer
en bagnole une fois par semaine
maintenant j'ai décidé de me déplacer en
vélo alors du haut de mon grand âge ça
me fait faire 60 portes dans la journée
ce n'est pas un exploit mais ce qui à ma
modeste échelle me fait du bien quand
même et j'ai décidé de le faire parce
que ça me fait du bien et que ça me
détend donc j'ai pas vu le moins
ne pas être en voiture j'ai vu le plus
que ça me permet de faire un peu
d'exercice
et que je trouve ça agréable
le plus c'est instantané et en fait
toute la difficulté dans cette affaire
de climat et d'énergie c'est d'essayer
d'arriver à trouver des plus de court
terme
parce que le plus de long terme est un
truc qui me fait avancer personne il
faut que la motivation elle soit là à
court terme dont tout à l'heure vous
avez cité l'exemple de l'abonnement
il faut qu'il ya un plus associé à ça à
court terme nécessairement sinon on n'y
arrive pas alors le plus peu et de temps
en temps il est le fait de se retrouver
dans la norme sociale
ça c'est quelque chose qui est un ami
mathématicien qui par ailleurs est un
des fondateurs de dauphine qui avait dit
un jour jamais on arrivera à résoudre le
problème du changement climatique on
entend un problème économique jamais il
faut que ça devienne un problème éthique
dit autrement il faut que ça il faut oui
si vous avez le nez qui vous démange un
repas et vous avez envie furieuse envie
de vous forger le
marina pour en sortir des crottes de nez
vous n'allez pas le faire parce qu'en
fait ça vous ferait sortir de la norme
sociale c'était vraiment avec des bons
copains qui font pareil mais sinon
n'avait pas le faire parce que ça vous
ça vous fait sortir de la norme sociale
et rester dans la norme sociale est un
truc important donc ça ça peut aussi
être quelque chose qui un jour va jouer
voilà mais il faut il faut il faut qu'il
ya un plus de court terme dans toute
action qui va aller dans le bon sens sur
le long terme sinon effectivement ça
marchera pas et donc ça c'est pas du
tout du ressort des polytechniciens
c'est du ressort des gens qui savent
sonder les âmes et comprendre comment
est ce que des gens ont envie de faire
des choses qui sont différentes de ce
qu'ils faisaient avant
alors juste on est désolé mais c'est 23h
trad on a répond déjà pas mal de
questions dans la plaie en plein paris
par internet aussi donc on va être
obligé d'arrêter je voulais encore une
fois remercier jean marc jancovici est
revenue ici à rodez
[Applaudissements]
vous remercier vous aussi pouvoir avec
ou pas pour votre présence vous pouvez
c'est la mascotte
d'entrée ça risque de faire bizarre par
contre est
donc juste pour vous remercier vous de
votre présence aussi on va dans la
mesure des règles sanitaires autant que
possible relance et les cycles de
conférences qui nous sont chères c'est à
dire qu'on organise environ 2 à 3 par an
sur des thèmes variés mais c'est
toujours intéressant de discuter sur sur
ce genre de sujet
et un dernier point aussi on a lancé il
ya tout juste un an une chaîne de
podcasts qui s'appelle dans leurs bottes
qui j'en parlais à monsieur jancovici
avant de démarrer la conférence dans le
but en fait est de présenter
l'agriculture et nous agriculteurs sous
un jour un peu différent c'est à dire
c'est que c'est une interview ce genre
d'interview d'échangé pendant une heure
il ya on a dû tourner une trentaine
d'épisodes à peu près depuis le début
est donc en fait c'est pour montrer la
réalité de l'agriculture les jeunes
agriculteurs on est avant tout des
jeunes comme les autres et voilà c'est
ça parle de nous donc je vous invite à
aller à aller faire un tour si
disponible sur toutes les plateformes le
de podcasts classique voilà merci encore
à tous merci messieurs comme ici et à
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est désolé d'habitude on paye un coup
à la ferme et bien sûr vous comprenez
que la situation
ne le ne le permet pas